ladies and gentlemen it is a is a dark
day in american history
there was an insurrection at the capitol
never forget 6 16 2022 when staffers and
comedians and individuals associated
with stephen colbert
breached the capitol building after
hours without authorization let in yes
by a democratic member of congress
our democracy i'm sorry our
constitutional republic
is truly at risk
uh no uh in all seriousness here's the
real story this is actually crazy so i'm
sitting down in the green room i i'm i
turn on fox news and jesse waters comes
on and says that seven people
associated with the colbert's late show
were arrested for breaching the capitol
building they were unauthorized they
were banging on doors and screaming
apparently uh the report is that they
were let in by adam schiff now we're
hearing it's nine people including some
well-known comics as well as staffers
for the late show with stephen colbert
so it's fascinating obviously i'm not
literally comparing this to what
happened on january 6 but it is kind of
a weird irony
we have the january 6 hearings going on
right now and you have several comedians
breaching the building they were
instructed to leave apparently they were
let in by schiff
i wonder if adam schiff is going to be
held accountable at all so we'll talk
about that we got a bunch of other news
too we got uh uh i believe it was corn
his name right that senator who wants to
gun control that's what it is yeah he's
getting booed at a gop convention people
were throwing his liners in the trash oh
i really really want to talk about that
and uh i think i think we'll roll with
that obviously a lot of news in the uh
in the economy
because everybody expected to get really
bad democrats are already plotting
replacing joe biden let's be real they
have been for some time so we'll get
into all of that stuff joining us
tonight to talk about all of that is
vishbura how you doing thank you tim i'm
an america first activist in operative
i've worked with the new york young
republican club i've been the producer
for uh war room with steve bannon
i've been
i've worked closely with matt gates uh
in the house of representatives uh i'm
also one of the main players behind the
hunter biden laptop story right here
anybody who's ever got a copy of the
hunter biden laptop has pretty much got
it from me wow yeah well then should be
interesting we also have force cooper
yep so my name is forrest cooper i exist
in two different worlds one of them
being philosophy the other one being
violence and how we understand it uh and
i am here for my fourth appearance
enjoying my time here
so my politics is my own but i'm really
concerned about i like to i like to
focus on questions of gun control and
whether it's arbitrary and what's the
point and then you can find me on
twitter now if you've been following if
you've seen us on or me on your show i'm
on twitter now unfortunately you have a
lot of experience in uh war conflict
crisis yep uh seven deployments four of
them prior with ranger battalion i've
spent plenty of time overseas i was over
in ukraine for a little bit recently
um but that was more for journalism
so i really want to talk about um you
know obviously tim poole loves talking
about civil war
so we'll get into that especially
considering what's going on with this uh
this capital breach and what it really
means and what they'll say about it plus
where this goes in terms of there's
another big story out of new mexico we
talked about otero county where they're
refusing to certify the election a court
order came down saying you have to and
this guy corey griffin was like nope not
going to do it so nobody knows what that
means they're like if he doesn't do it
what happens
no one knows is there just no election
well we'll find out we got lukowski i'm
i'm pretty sure forrest is here to
assassinate me after the show so that uh
stay tuned
my name is lukerdowski if we are
change.org i am your humble t-shirt
vendor today i'm wearing a shirt that
gets me a lot of thumbs up it says if
you trust the government you don't know
history i think it's important for a lot
of people to see this message if you
agree you could go on the best political
thebestpoliticalshirts.com and get
yourself one also uh today will be my
last day for a little bit here on this
broadcast i will be missing you guys i
will definitely miss tim
ian lydia and uh even this grinning
malacca right in front of me that
couldn't be happier about the jews no
i'm really sad
man luke is going on an unpaid
suspension for inappropriate behavior
that's true he cheated while we were
playing uh video games also called me
potato man many times no that's fine
all right finally i i can talk to hr
then then i can talk to hr and that's
fine you would you would
karen i want to i want to point out that
your shirt is correct if you trust the
government you don't know history as
someone who doesn't know history i also
don't trust the government so i want
that to be said at least you admit it
yeah well look i'm i'm not gonna pretend
to be something i'm not yes and luke is
it assassination if you know it's coming
uh maybe i don't know we'll see what
happens after the show it's a question
for another day rhetoric's making me
feel unsafe um so my name is james
coughlin i make cartoons uh at a youtube
channel called freedom tunes we just
released a cartoon yesterday that i
think you guys will really like speaking
of assassinations and assassination
attempts it's pretty spicy i think
you'll enjoy it we also
just started a website so if you want to
support independent content help us get
free from big tech and get an extra
cartoon every week go over to
freedomtunes.com and become a member for
five bucks a month thank you so much i
am loving the vibe tonight it's gonna be
very fun conversation we have a lot of
different expertises here so i'm looking
forward to getting into it before we get
started head over to timcast.com become
a member and support our work and our
journalists as a member you'll get
access to exclusive segments from this
show we have they got monday for
thursday at 11 p.m and we have this
massive library by now of all of these
different guests and conversations so it
really is great stuff and we appreciate
all of you becoming members supporting
us but you're also supporting our
journalists who are fact checking
reporting on all this news every single
day challenging the machine and you are
supporting websites and news outlets
that use alternative infrastructure we
do not use big tech silicon valley for
the website we said garbage well
obviously we use some stuff but for the
most part our infrastructure is rumble
our video player is rumble and we have
many more announcements i'd love to say
every aspect of the site is 100 off of
silicon valley
we are actively working on that now
building new infrastructure and signing
deals and all of that stuff we will have
many more announcements because a lot of
stuff is happening behind the scenes our
intent is to do what we can to say no to
the machine and help create competition
so go to timkes.com but don't forget
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this video right now
everywhere you can if you really want to
help us out word of mouth is the best
way to help let's jump into that first
story from just the news
capital breach
seven individuals some tied to comedian
colbert caught
unapproved in complex let me see if i
can pull up this twitter it looks like
we're getting like a weird thing
happening with the yeah we keep trying
to resize it
yeah whatever you can read it so here we
go we got this uh this twitter thread
from chad pergram who says
fox confirms that groups of persons
associated with the late show stephen
colbert were arrested uh last night and
charged with illegal entry to house
office buildings after hours fox is told
that people were arrested in the
longworth house office building the
group was in the cannon house office
building earlier in the day trying to
get interviews around the time of the
one six committee hearing however uscp
shooed them away because they did not
have proper press credentials however
the group the group surfaced later in
the night after the capital complex was
closed to the public fox is told they
took pictures and videos around the
offices of house minority leader kevin
mccarthy and lauren bobert
sounds like an insurrection if you were
to ask me i mean that's what the media
was saying about uh uh who was it was it
uh who was that who's that was a
congressman right loudermilk loudermilk
very louder
they were saying he was leading a tour
and helping people or giving them
insider information what is this why
would they why would they be why would
they take pictures they say they were
unescorted and arrested in charge of the
legal entry they were arrested near beau
bert's office released overnight they've
confirmed all of their names nine people
now i can confirm several of these
people do work for stephen colbert some
of them i believe which is uh uh one of
these guys i don't know is is the voice
of that comedian that dog that robert
smigiel is that who that is yes what's
the dog trying to try him yeah yeah
oh he actually goes on to say that
uscp have issued the following statement
on june 16 2022 at approximately 8 30
p.m u.s capitol police received a call
for a disturbance in the longworth house
office building responding officers
observed seven individuals unescorted
without congressional id in a six-floor
hallway the building was closed visitors
and these individuals were determined to
be part of a group that had been
directed by the uscp to leave the
building i got to tell you my friends
this is worse than january 6. how so you
think i'm joking i'm not joking i mean
that seriously on january 6 many of the
people who entered the building
walked up with no signs with nothing and
had the doors opened for them by the
police who then went to take selfies
with them
those people one guy so far cause
there's been a few uh uh jury uh bench
trials one of these guys was acquitted
because the judge said
cops opened the door and let him in
that's not trespassing
there was another guy who tried claiming
the same thing but he's on video
climbing through a broken window and
over broken vest sorry that's not going
to fly you know you're trespassing yeah
these people were told to leave
they came back
and according to
uh uh i believe we have a it was a tweet
from jonathan turley and the statement
made by uh it wasn't for jonathan turley
tweeted what jesse waters reported that
it was adam schiff and maybe one of the
staffers who let them in the building so
you have a member of congress letting
them letting them in the building after
they were told by the police not to be
there
that's almost as bad as the writers now
there wasn't they weren't engaging in
violence the writers on january 6
obviously you know arrest them and
charge them as appropriate but these
what they did is worse than what the
manga mimos did when they when they
blindly walked in confused so i'd like
to see several fbi raids uh maybe some
uh misdemeanor charges that result in a
year of solitary confinement uh what say
you good sir well let me ask you this
tim what do you think if let's say those
producers were reaching out to many
members of of the house trying to get in
uh to the the capitol you know via
requests and stuff maybe adam schiff
wasn't the first one in fact a a source
from the house sent me an email from
jake plunkett sent on june 6th hi
reaching out on behalf of robert smeigle
and the triumph the insult dog he'll be
in dc on june 15th and the 16th covering
the jan 6 hearings wants to do some
comedy bits with members of both sides
of the aisle if you haven't seen triumph
he's the insult comic dog and uh with
conan and recently had his own hulu
special we've done bits with everyone
from barney frank to ted cruz and corey
booker we're very much interested in
doing comedy for both sides that's an
email that was sent on june 6th now if
adam schiff actually let these guys in
right there's a process i used to work
in the house and that in the longworth
building i worked there and in order for
you to get access to to the office
buildings as press you have to go
through the admin and get the the house
admin and get press credentials
the reason you would go to a member to
let you in is so that you're let in
without having to declare that you're
press
right and so that's and not only that
can you bypass security
well you
you can't you
i have to be registered in by the
somebody from the office of the of the
congress member so they they're you're
on record that you're in but there are
rules if you're a visitor to one of
these offices for a congress member
you're not allowed to even roam the
halls of the office building what about
after hours when the building's closed
definitely not because you need an offer
you need somebody a staff member of the
congress member who let you in to be
escorting you through the halls at all
times so my question is
if you were let in after hours is it
would that bypass would you be able to
bypass security well adam schiff has to
answer
no you can't you somebody had to let him
in through the doors right then they let
him loose through the building what i
mean is
is there is there a way to open doors
for people that does not bring them
through any kind of security oh no no no
no everyone goes secure everybody goes
through that's what i want to make sure
yeah i'm like did they open a side door
and even after 7 p.m there's only one
door it's called the 24-hour entrance at
the longworth building there's only one
door you can get in after 7 p.m so
you're saying that he signed the men he
brought them through a staffer or
himself had to have signed them in wow
and they were they're up uh so uh on
jesse waters apparently they were like
banging on doors and yelling and that's
how the cops were alerted to it we need
more reporting to come out cause this
story is just coming out now here's the
crazy thing this happened yesterday at 8
30 p.m what how are we just now finding
out about it there's people in the chat
room calling this uh in soy erection
which i just wanted to note here and you
made a good point tim especially on
january 6th there was
doors that were extremely heavy that
were closed with magnets that were only
opened because of a code that was input
directly by someone from the inside that
knew the code that was able to open the
doors on january 6th what happened here
this video the cops opening the door and
the cop even says don't agree with it
but i respect it yeah yeah so so you
know
what happened here we don't know maybe
they're they're trying to do another big
pfizer
saying and uh
sang and dance routine uh trying to
promote more procedures who knows we
don't know we do need more reporting to
find out exactly what was going on here
it would be funny if all of those people
were dressed up like giant vaccinations
running around i i think you guys aren't
taking this seriously enough it sounds
to me like adam schiff came dangerously
close to overthrowing the united states
government you're right you're right we
need hearings immediately absolutely
adam schiff
i mean let's be serious though
if it's true that he let them in i mean
that's way worse than january 6. donald
trump said peacefully march to the
capitol and and cheer on politicians
something like that were there
republican elected officials who let
people into the capital on january 6th
no yeah did any sign
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying this is
so look
the the the left will always try to
conflate all of january 6 with just the
riot in on the one side of the building
i'm not talking about that those people
who are fighting with cops and smashing
stuff and hitting like those people will
get charged arrest them charge them yes
make sure it's appropriate you get what
you get
i'm not a fan of what they're doing with
the the solitary confinement for a year
or anything that's that's egregious but
if you're if you're riding you get
arrested
but there's videos of people just
walking up confused there's no fences
there's no barricades and then the cops
literally open the door and they wave to
people as they walk in with their flags
one cop stops they take a selfie
together and they're like yeah thank you
apparently one guy claimed that the cops
were actually like yeah come on in
there's actually video of cops fanning
people like this
now the argument there was the capitol
police said the cop was fanning the
police not the people well you got a
problem there if there's regular people
standing there confused and you're going
like this and motioning forward and
they're like okay yeah they think you're
telling them to come in that's also a
very strange excuse taking selfies with
insurrectionists is not really a good
look also hold on that that seems like a
ridiculous story so if there were people
who were just mobbing the compound right
and we're calling security over and
those people are at the door i'm not
going like this
to gesture security to come over to help
us right that's not how that works
that's insane that is such an insane
argument like you know i was just i was
just doing a general waving motion into
the building because i wanted one
specific person to stop everyone else
from getting in the building
they were telling the other officers to
pull back so here's okay well maybe i
could see that but here's a silly
question the
january 6th in the january 6 event
insurrection is probably going to be one
of the most documented
events in american history
even now it's been what a year and a
half old yeah right
there's so much documentation on this
that there are dissertations that will
be written about people's dissertations
about people's opinions about what they
thought they saw whatever
has anybody and i mean anybody that has
the cogency
to ask
maybe somebody who knows anything about
security regarding security protocols
security operations i mean it's not a
complicated situation the whole fanning
thing is ridiculous
we we need to get to the bottom of the
uh 529 insurrection 529 instructions in
all seriousness that's right five nine
well more roughly two-thirds of
americans want to look into the 2020
riots according to polling data
less than half want to look into january
6. less than half agree with the january
6th commission you mean the 529
insurrection yeah that's right the 529
never forget never forget and i never
are you familiar with 529
i live in minneapolis i'm familiar i
heard it was mostly peaceful 539 in
washington dc when violent leftists
tried tearing the fence down and set
fire to one of the white house guard
posts set fire to st john's church and
forced the president to retreat to a
bunker attacked journalists and the
police had to come and defend the white
house from this insurrection on 529 529
yeah yeah 529. i remember that okay you
mentioned um
that they were this is one of the most
documented events and it is curious why
aren't they releasing the security
camera footage why not really solve the
security camera from 529 well from
january january 6th was more documented
but yeah both
and they won't or the federal
involvement and
exactly at least information about how
many agents uh you know were there and
were participating and also you know the
fore knowledge with basic events that
were on facebook saying that this was
going to happen and then this was all
something that happened
what about the supposed pipe bombs that
were just near where kamala harris was
that they decided to stop investigating
to stop talking i have a real question
um
after january 6 a bunch of leftists
started doxxing all of as many people as
they could posting their photos and
faces no one did that for 5 29. i mean
that seriously like at the white house
you have all this video of people trying
to
break down the fence they actually tore
down the barricades they actually set
fire to one of the guard posts and a
church
the right is not playing this game i was
going to say as as uh as an activist
i've seen this over and over again we're
just not willing to do what the left is
willing to do to take us out right like
this the sedition hunters page is what
you're talking about where they're going
out and doxxing you know people who were
part of the insurrection or whatever but
we don't do that why not uh we we have
this i i think that the right has a
problem of of actually just participate
where the space is available why don't
we have our own version of splc or adl
that just goes and labels people
communists or you know marxists or you
know woke uh you know
because
because you know the way i see it is
like
the quote-unquote right is a is a
disparate group of random factions that
disagree with each other on so many
different things yeah
not even necessarily individualists i
mean conservatives are more
individualists but they're more
but to be but to be contrarian here is
is that going to be the right strategy
because someone did something bad should
we do something bad too and use the
state and the government and the deep
states to go after people politically so
so i i understand the paradigm i'm just
playing uh
it's not bad to call out bad people
right they're just duplicitous there is
right-wing uh media matters sort of i i
think it's unfair to say necessarily but
news busters are familiar with
newspapers so they they watch all of the
all these cable channels and then call
out the lies and the media i respect
that media matters lies about people in
the media so but it's an inversion it's
you know
i like what newsbusters does i don't
like what media matters does but at a
core they're both watching tv and then
publishing their their opinions on it
right so there is that counterpart
for the splc my whole thing is just
match them at the front i don't need you
to win just match them right because
then it opens up other
fronts in the war where we can actually
overtake them well right the question is
we just get we get we get kicked in too
much from too many angles but if you
look at the splc they they lie they
slander they've been sued successfully
by individuals that they they they lied
about they lied about me they lied about
me too they took a speech that i did and
they took one particular sentence that i
said and they matched it up with a
sentence that i said later to make it to
make me sound like i was calling for a
revolution when i was calling for an
evolution and and people being better
themselves individually so so they're
liars they're cheaters i don't think we
should strive to become what they are
and and i know i know where you're
coming from i'm saying no there's no
one's saying that no no no but but what
you were saying i think was kind of
matched by that well i think that first
of all nobody would call
we call the splc liars right splc
wouldn't say what they're doing is lying
and there's nobody that comes out a
third party sort of a court of law did
oh okay so if court of law did fine
right
and
they committed
several individuals including me they
retracted and apologized and corrected
it and a bunch of my friends end up on
that list too right but who has the
does everyone who gets put on that list
have the resources to be able to
challenge that right that that's the
problem so so there's a really good
example you could take with anything
that happens in the gun industry or or
the gun culture or it's like oh well
that guy got hit and so no everyone just
like leaves him alone for a while oh
he'll figure it out and what i'm saying
is that
i think you're identifying that
in many ways this the left circles the
wagons
and they protect their own and there's
there's a lot of things that you can go
through real quickly so i'll just launch
them one at a time um it was zooby who
said
um and uh calling someone a hypocrite
only matters if they have integrity i'm
paraphrasing import poorly but like okay
we know that doesn't work the splc
is not an honest organization okay we
know that so then they're not credible
we don't use them because they're
credible but somebody else will because
it's advantageous do you fight fire with
fire sometimes sometimes however what i
think a more critical condition is why
does the conservative party not use the
department of justice to actually do
justice and i don't mean this in the
well actually mentality right but it's
you look at all the all the the these
criticisms across the uh
the 529
issue you look at are the 529
insurrection you look at the the things
that happened in minneapolis the things
that happened in kenosha it's why don't
you actually just i don't know maybe do
your job right so and because if you're
not doing justice you're not the
department of justice and if you're not
doing justice as the department of
justice you should find a new job
you should be removed and and you don't
you do i do not think you win in the
game of attrition with people who are
already committed to a zealous
ideology that will never stop maybe
abolishing these corrupted institutions
might be something better instead of
them being weaponized against the
political parties because when another
political party goes into power they're
going to be using the same tools that
they use on the other party well here
perfect perfect example would be what
was her name what the
the view the gal from the the view who
said that uh gun gun laws in america
would change if black joy behar right
yes if black people had them right okay
do you censor her do you cut her from
the film or do you cut her from no you
ignore her
so she's she's not a serious she's not a
serious speaker and and as that
continues you encourage over the long
tail decision to build your community to
build your friends to focus if you want
to defeat ignorant people you isolate
them from the halls of intelligence she
wasn't wrong though joy behar
what she's saying she's not talking
about conservatives these so joy behar
on the view says that when black people
get guns the gun laws will change
now we as
people who don't like racism or who uh
like guns we hear that and we're like
that's ridiculous like we would ever
support that race no no no it's
these uppity liberals of course want
more gun control and especially if
minorities they don't like our getting
this look what happened with the black
panthers it's exactly that was that was
california that was san francisco
absolutely it was california and san
francisco in a different time i don't
want to go down that road too far what i
do want to go down to is the point of
white fragility what did we learn from
the book white fragility the author is a
terrible person and she wants to project
that on everybody else and she's racist
she's a racist who wants to project her
racism on everybody else so a an honest
academic would look at that and say
forrest we need to have an honest kind
of a conversation about this i see i i
see people on the right internalize what
joy behar said and um when you
internalize that pain you assume they're
talking about you when they're actually
talking about themselves so when they
project when they say these things i
just always assume they're talking about
themselves you know why
people
have a worldly have have their world
view and they assume i i should say low
low iq people assume everyone else must
see the world the same way they do
therefore if they don't agree with me
it's because they're lying
so someone like joy behar when she says
that she's actually talking more about
herself and what she feels than what
anyone else actually thinks
i don't think she's i don't think she
has a low iq i think she's just mean
i i think it's i think it's i think it's
fueled from spite it's just rage but why
would you say why would you say that
about anybody why would you say that
about anybody is that the soul thing
that motivates them is racism because
she's a racist exactly so she needs to
spend some time figuring out who she is
she sees the world through this lens and
assumes that's why people would do
something she does not understand the
fact that you know we're all i don't
know are you you're familiar with marge
terrain yes yeah we're we're fans of
black guns matter and maj toure and the
work he does
and uh
it's like she doesn't even know he
exists i mean literally she probably
doesn't i think that she sees this world
then she says everyone else must think
the same way as me but i'm a good person
because i don't act on it we're all like
no we don't think that we think you're a
racist this this is just a a modernized
version of white man's burden right
that's all this is i look uh it's hard
for me to be this good white person you
know it's my burden
to have to go around and say this stuff
i'm just trying to speak spent uh uh
sense to you folks are you talking about
like the 1800s white man's birth yeah
it's the same thing yeah the part where
like we have
things like travel and medicine and
written language we should spread that
around the world yeah but they've taken
it they've taken that and just injected
it into everything yeah they call it
they call it white savior complex right
yeah it's the same thing it's the same
thing they think they know better for
you that's the whole like remember that
guy in uh california where he was
cheering on the writing and then he's
like you see his twitter thread where
he's like yes yes do it yeah wait a
minute why are you coming to my
neighborhood don't come to my name go
downtown and it's like he actually i
think didn't he actually say like go
downtown where the park where the poor
people lived and he was mad they're
going to beverly hills i'm like bro
they're coming to eat the rich you're
not safe they've been saying this for a
while i mean they don't say eat the rich
because they're hungry they say eat the
rich because they're greedy yeah so
exactly i'm still working this idea out
i don't claim to know the answer here i
don't know the solutions but i think
maybe it would be more advantageous to
stop relying on corrupted institutions
to do the right thing and i think uh
moving away from them defunding them
abolishing them i think would be a
better strategy than saying hey bill
barr mr c.i.a do the right thing here um
i i i think it would be better to to you
know
i don't know some people say play fire
with fire and i understand that argument
i understand where you guys are coming
from uh but but my knee-jerk reaction is
like wait what we're doing here is we're
adding more fuel to the fire and it's
already very hot in this room well
that's my point of view so i think
you're and i might be wrong and i might
be wrong well you might be and let me
tell you why uh you i think you're
seizing a lot on the argument of state
intervention and just setting that aside
for a moment because i don't even know i
don't think we agree entirely there but
when
he mentioned something like having our
own version of the splc obviously we're
not saying we should have an
organization that lies but the point is
the left has re-engineered the culture
such that being accused of having any
kind of conservative value comes with a
very swift and significant social cost
but they target attack and harass
individuals and i think that it is a
very good idea for conservatives to push
for a culture where there is a social
cost to being a communist right if you
are going to go out there and say i
support the ideology which has resulted
in hundreds of millions of innocent
people being slaughtered
folks should probably not want to
associate with if you want if you want
to advocate for the abolition of private
property start with yourself if you're
not willing to do that you don't believe
it but that that is an old tale that
what you're dealing with is an asymmetry
of ideas an asymmetry in the side of
warfare you look at after nuclear after
nuclear weapons were created the idea of
warfare had to change you can't put the
genie back in the bottle after the
machine gun horse charges didn't matter
anymore after
bomber planes large formations of people
don't work anymore
standard armor didn't matter when
gunpowder became ubiquitous it took time
but if eventually gunpowder defeated
armor so yeah and then armor became
massive tanks which then were our def
you know right now we have drones you
having a tank of battalion is
functionally useless against a powerful
western military what happened after
this history lesson at we saw in well
not history i don't need to talk down
that's not the right way of saying it um
but after world war ii what were the
next major conflicts korea my
grandfather was a pow for three years so
i heard a lot of stories um and then so
there was that and then there was
vietnam and you saw the rise of
insurgency warfare insurgency has become
such a buzzword amongst the military
elite that it's like i'm cool i said
insurgency metaphysics polymath banana
peel but whatever um so the point being
said though is how does an asymmetry
work the the left has functionally and
fully adopted asymmetrical warfare from
the side of what we had called terrorism
but an insurgency it is a situation
where i get to harm you but if you do
what i do to you if you if you
reciprocate that's bad so you see this
within the in the the conflict the uh
the riots in minneapolis the riots were
a really good example the
antifa or the rioters will provoke a
response and use that response as
justification for further
further evidence of their need for
revolution who's been calling for a
revolution this entire time
it hasn't been the right yeah right well
look
understanding insurgency conflict how to
fight against a counter insurgency the
purpose of an insurgency is not to
defeat you in a military battle it's to
break your will to the system how do
americans under how do how does the
right or how do americans defeat this
social contagion that is this insurgency
which is both bred on on
our soil and abroad
is you remember the foundations that
built our country it's almost the lord
of the rings plot all over again you
have to understand who you are and where
you come from and then live up to those
virtues that is very important that you
mention that because one of the huge
problems right now is that conservatives
but i would say americans overall and
people living in western societies have
no idea
what their values are or what values
upon which their society has been
founded and so when the left comes along
and they try to deconstruct
a lot of people are completely helpless
they don't know how to defend and
justify the values that our society
promotes they're incapable of doing it i
think you're right that we need to know
what we believe and we don't yeah i
don't i think this is where we kind of
differ because i don't see the left as
the main problem here i see a divide and
conquer agenda i see voting for the
lesser of two evils that is continuing
to plague this country i see a duopoly i
see fifth generational warfare being
raged on the american people and i think
the people that are in power are using
the left right now because they're the
most easily to get used now they're the
most easily to push this agenda through
because it's convenient now but as soon
as it becomes unconvenient for the
larger agenda for the larger fifth
genera fifth generation warfare
enslavement of humanity they're going to
be using a right-wing element of it
that's also going to be pushing on a
different front that's going to be
taking away our rights and our economic
abilities uh to to survive and prosper
so more hold on how do you
i just want to say this one thing and
then i'll let you jump in so more than
one thing can be true at a time it can
absolutely be the case that the ruling
elites see the left is convenient
revolutionaries to destroy the existing
social order and then bring to fruition
whatever it is that they're seeking to
transform our society into it is also
the case that the strategy by which they
do that is to have the left completely
erode any and all moral surrounding
family values destroy the family and
then the government comes into that
vacuum and usurps the responsibility
that the family normally has and they do
this with the participation right what
we have to do oh i totally agree with
you on that but that's part of why we do
have to fight left-wing ideology and and
defend and fight for the family so i
don't think it's enough to say the left
is being used by these tyrants therefore
we just look at the tyrants we actually
have to fight the ideology itself
because it's useful to them for a reason
so my opinion is i think we're in such a
desperate situation we should be
fighting against the enslavement the
evisceration of our rights and the
destruction of our financial futures
whether you're on the left right or
center i think it's it's time more than
ever to let go of of of these kind of
differences and say hey we're actually
being really hurt here we're actually
being really screwed over here and
unless we we come together unless we
realize that we're all in this boat
together we're all going down as a
sinking ship so like i don't want the
people who groom children oh look look i
hear what you're saying but i don't
think you understand the deep
ideological divide between in the united
states from left and right
you have people who have no moral
framework they they they will say
simultaneously stop and frisk is bad and
red flag laws are good even though
they're variants of the exact same thing
and one's even worse red flag laws stop
and frisk on steroids they're foreign
why no moral framework so when you go to
them and say hey you know we need to
come together because all these bad
things are happening they'll go oh
you're right of course and as soon as
you turn around they'll they'll hit you
in the back yeah i'm not saying it's a
good strategy i'm not saying it's even
going to work
it doesn't it doesn't work okay well
it's it's it's it's um isaiah 5 20. they
will call good evil and evil good you
cannot have
you cannot have you cannot break bread
and have commonality with somebody who
calls what you call good evil so problem
that you have do we focus on the left do
we focus on the globalist do we focus on
all these you know what they all saw the
the point that you're saying they solve
the same question but but you can't you
can't you can't just advocate for the
family you have to have the one fourth
you have to build first i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna agree with luke on this
one i think if we just compromise with
the child drag shows then maybe no no no
no no no that's not what i'm saying no
that's not what i said what do you think
not what are you in the same boat as us
because you're saying not absolutely i
see i see the right wing political
establishment willingly going along with
this and pretending like they're like
they're going to be helping us when
they're not i think that's what i think
there's a myth too i think there's a i
think there's a divide first of all of
our understanding of right wing and like
republicans right the republicans in dc
and then the republicans across the
nation are two
totally different things right for
example you're talking about why didn't
the fbi or the cia move on 529 right
insurrection the insurrection who was
the president at the time donald trump
that was his fbi that was his cia why
didn't they move right and then you're
definitely not going to get a move out
of the out of a biden fbi or doj the the
problem is so entrenched in dc right the
the fbi is is a bunch of it used to be a
republican stronghold but republicans
for of dc right you're james comey's of
the world bill barr uh robert mueller
right
this is the uniparty right there there
is one belief in the dc realm right
one when you're outside you know in west
virginia new york or whatever uh and
you're it's left versus right democrat
versus republican but when once you get
to dc once you win that battle and you
get to dc the fight becomes the
incumbents versus everybody else yeah so
the problem you have is that the
when you try to abolish the fbi or you
try to abolish these corruptions
i'm with you on that right but first you
have to get in the guys who believe that
into those positions because you can't
abolish that institution while you have
james comey or a bill bar or robert
mueller there in fact i wanted to the
the whole mueller investigation and that
you know james comey gets fired then the
special uh council gets appointed for
and robert mueller gets selected as as a
special counsel if a couple of things
were adjusted slightly differently what
you would have actually had end up with
is that there's a universe somewhere out
there where
bill barr would have been selected the
special counsel and then donald trump
would have hired robert mueller to head
the fbi it would it's the you got you're
dealing with the same pool of talent no
matter what right that's the problem the
pool of talent you could draw on to put
into the institutions
that and so then it goes back to what
you're saying build the family build the
community right because first you have
to build the community then you go and
take the halls of power and then you put
the community in that hall of power and
then you do what you want
that's the problem but just for the
record i i don't stand by any groomers i
don't think you should be working or
lying with any type of people who are
hurting children
but the one point i want to make here is
that it's both republicans and democrats
that are going to jeffrey epstein's
island
i need to address that point you're
making because when you say you go to
them and say we're being really hurt by
this you're talking about people who
overtly and and uh
with pride particularly to clarify those
people i i'm saying absolutely not you
cannot support people who hurt small
children especially with how evil
they're doing it especially with the
damages that they're causing them so
what i'm saying is is that the
conversation should be what i'm saying
is the conversation should be a little
bit more nuanced rather than generalized
that's just the perspective that i'm
trying to implement so so here's what i
would recommend go to someone you see as
a democrat voter or someone's perceived
as a left and say do you agree with sex
changes for children do you agree with
child drag shows if they say no okay
let's have a conversation if they say
yes which ninety-five percent probably
will maybe we don't know five
okay have a nice day
what you're asking about tim is the same
thing that comes into the gun control
conversation is when was the last time
you had an honest conversation about
this about gun control as as a whole
like okay
my i was politically introduced into the
gun control conversation what
conversation okay that's such a
let's let's do this let's start the gun
control conversation with an article
though cool so this is from cnn politics
john cornyn top republican negotiator on
gun package booed at texas gop
convention i saw a photo apparently they
were throwing lanyards with his name in
it in the garbage
and then they booed the guy on his pole
for the chat i just want to point this
out when we're talking about politics
and the establishment uniparty you've
got republicans who say okay democrats
we'll compromise and give up g give up
uh
given to gun control and democrats who
say the moment you do will call for
twice as much
so the the direction only moves towards
more gun control where's where's the
republican negotiation with democrats on
them abolishing certain gun laws or
repealing certain gun laws never happens
never ever well this is what they
constantly say
why won't the republicans compromise
with us okay well by definition a
compromise involves both sides getting
something you're literally just asking
for concessions right and the
republicans give them and there
shouldn't be any concessions when it
comes to our god-given rights and i
think that's a stance that we should be
making saying hey we've given enough to
the government we we've given them all
of our money we've given them all of our
privacy we've given them all of our
trust and they have deceived us every
single day and when you look at history
when populations disarm when populations
give up their weapons when populations
become defenseless it's when governments
are able to do whatever they want with
them and i think it's it's extremely
dangerous where we're headed towards as
a country and i i think there should be
a criticism right now on the republicans
here more than the democrats because
it's the republicans here that are
allowing a lot of this to to move
through oh yeah so this is the problem
with republicans in dc i i despise
republicans in dc there's all you could
count on your hand how many of them you
could actually rely on to be about what
they're about right john cornyn one of
these guys the problem with the senate
is that it's a retirement home right
they go and raise the age on being able
to buy guns why because they're well
over the age right it doesn't affect
them and so you so the senate
republicans cornyn is already
putting up the signal right now that
he's about to get blown out the same
thing happened to uh uh
jacobs i think chris jacobs in new york
23 he came out he was a house republican
in a super conservative district in new
york right the r plus 23. he comes out
and says you know what i'm willing to to
uh compromise and vote for gun control
in about three or four days later he had
to come out and say i'm no longer
seeking the election right
yeah because that's the that's how much
pushback that he got that he realized
like oh i i said the one thing that just
ruined my entire political career can
you recall him can we do a recall or
something for senators um of well no and
you can't do oh i think it'll go state
by state what you'll be able to do with
the senator but i don't think i don't
think you can recall a senator but
in that moment that showed you that
still the the uproar from the people
pushed that guy jacobs out and to break
a little news on this show i'm actually
going to uh be the comms director for
carl palladino in new york 23 to go and
bring that seat and and bring it to a
real conservative carl palladino if he
if he's elected he will be the mtg of
the north he will raise hell in in the
in in the capital and we need a guy like
that a lot of gun control bills that
need to be repealed and and carl will
stand up because and uh that's that
district was challenged on that gun
control uh bit right there that seat
opened because of that so paul knows
what the deal is he's gonna go make sure
where our
inalienable rights are protected it's
really easy to look at gun rights and
human rights in america let's remember
that the right to own a firearm is a
human right if you think otherwise you
can go find a way to not be a part of
talking but
um
diplomatic diplomatic rights they tried
getting a three-week waiting period for
all gun purchases look look at there
needs to be room for optimism here and
the room for optimism is in our
generation i am 32 years old i am
sunburnt from spending a week in south
dakota which has nothing to do with what
i'm about to say what does have
something to do with the is we live in a
generation where you could very well see
the nfa repealed we can see it i do not
believe in getting doomer pilled and
saying that's the national firearms act
yeah the national firearms act the
reason why you can't own you have to go
through a special process to own a
barrel that has a length shorter than 16
inches or to own a suppressor which
protects your hearing suppressors make
it safe for everyone yeah the the the
and this kind of comes back down to that
if you think that suppressors are like
hollywood quiet and super dangerous you
don't know what you're talking about
here's
here's the crazy thing too they have
handguns that are suppressed that means
they've made like hey we're going to
make this handgun it's going to be safer
it's not good it's going to be as
dangerous and they're like not that's an
nfa item it's an nfa item so to to to
break the stigma the why do you think he
got booed do you think he got booed
because he betrayed the republican party
or because he betrayed the american
people the people i'm telling you that
they booed him because he betrayed the
american people
and turns out when you betray the
american people and you're and you're
running for a republican you lose your
seat you betray the american people
and you're running for democrat you
become president
if you're if you betray the american
people and you're a democrat all you got
to do is come out and wave a flag or or
make some garbage statement and they'll
say sure whatever as long as we're
aligned socially so that can fit in yeah
you can you can bring economic rune upon
the people where they're literally
starving in the streets but you know
what at least he didn't make mean tweets
they're they're some people are
masochists you know adam schiff can lie
every single day he can push the
russiagate lies and people just like
they love it they love being pissed on
by this guy they're going to keep voting
for him but did you know that trump
called him watermelon head
and that's really no did he wrong and
that's really unpresidential yeah did he
do that yeah well i feel bad for
watermelons
well that's the thing you know adam
schiff and these guys they they sit in
really safe blue it all depends on the
political pressure at the end of the day
these guys are cold and calculated they
don't believe in a damn thing right and
so as long as that seed is sitting there
blue as hell and nobody can touch adam
schiff on a fundraising perspective or a
popularity perspective that guy's gonna
sit there for a while and if it gets out
of his hand it goes to the left it
doesn't go to the right right and so
this is this is the problem we don't do
enough uh i i believe on the the
conservative side we are not willing to
go into those districts and challenge
those people because
quite frankly it would cost you a lot of
money to do it and you'd probably still
lose right so i get that
but you but we have to build the
infrastructure and it's a long-term
project i'll tell you why i think one of
the factors that that is leading us to
civil war we've had on a bunch of people
on the show we've had on um
billy prempe for instance i love him but
he's run he was running as a republican
in a deep blue district yeah i know i
sho i helped him shoot an ad for him and
and he should have done that because
what's happened is
you get the gop that says okay we got to
be strategic we have x amount of dollars
that's a d plus seven maybe we shouldn't
invest so much money in that because
we're going to lose next year it's a d14
well we definitely don't want to invest
in there because we're going to lose
next year it's a d28 yeah this keeps
happening and it happens with
republicans as well it is hyper
polarizing the country you have areas
like adam schiff or nancy pelosi's
district or ocasio-cortez's district
where
she's in a d plus 28
and it's because republicans do not try
to spend to spend money there and get
their messaging out and because of that
now you've got
the amount of swing districts it's just
it's everything's being pushed further
and further left or right right but you
know what that has done though the
satisfaction with the representative for
each district has gone up since then
right so that is so there there's a
there's a a little that just makes it
worse and it it doesn't turn to the
polarization right because you're firmly
in with your guy right oh i love him
he's all the way to you know he's to the
right of me i'm uh love him right or to
the left of me
this is also part of the gerrymandering
you know argument right
do we how do what is the way we make
the maps right they have the the
communities of interest standard
my friend gavin wax just won his lawsuit
in new york
he was on this show before but we you
know we we uh he challenged the the
assembly maps got him thrown out special
master is going to have to redraw them
next year i think but how is it now that
it's going to be drawn out do you make
it so that everybody well what is fair
right in that sense and so fair is when
i win
correct that is the right answer
actually when it comes to politics
unfortunately unfortunately as much as
you hate it that is the right answer see
the issue is i mean
the left is
we should win because we should win
the right is we should win because we
propose these ideas that we think will
work better
many on the left think that's what
they're doing but then you run into
problems of
i mean look the modern left may be
different from where the left was 10
years ago i hear a lot of people like
bill maher and they rag on republicans
and it's like yeah you're talking about
like boomer republicans and stuff the
younger generation of people that align
in this direction are post liberal
libertarian moderate conservative etc
there's a wide range of voices on the
left they say things like we should
raise the minimum wage and you see yes
simple question what will that do
and then what how does it go sheamus oh
yeah so so this is how the left operates
they go i want good thing
i want good thing and then you go okay
so like
how are you gonna structure the
legislation to get that how are we gonna
pay for you want bad thing you want bad
thing he wants bad thing i don't i don't
want that you want bad thing you want
bad thing
he wants bad things and then they put
big big sign saying bad person bad
person bad person
perfect this is the you you ask the
question what are the things pushing us
towards uh civil war or open conflict
let's just call it open conflict the gun
debate is the perfect
example the gun why the gun debate why
the gun abortion is way abortion well
seventeen because pregnancy centers have
been fire bombs every four years right
now i mean every four years we have the
same talk in 2012 and 2013 this is when
i was introduced into the the political
gun conversation
uh what happened you had sandy hook yep
and then all of a sudden all of these
conversation all of these all gun
control gun control gun assault weapons
assault weapons assault weapons you know
magazines magazines magazines and unused
and people made bank
made money off of all of the ridiculous
things that people said they wanted to
propose all these ideas these do
something peoples if that is the extent
of your intellect wow man but
the point that i'm saying is you had all
of these arguments that were made that
all these gun pro gun control arguments
all every single one of them turned out
to be factually wrong ethically wrong or
just i don't know over tyranny so they
all collapsed and then four years later
we had parkland shooting what happened
to those old arguments came out of the
dust same exact argument same exact
arguments you could carbon copy them but
i don't think that is a contributing i
believe that's a contribution because
because the civil war no because the the
people on the right or the people who
support the private ownership of
firearms respond honestly and say well
these are your ideas but you're wrong so
i'll help you out and correct them and
then the people who propose gun control
go
they don't think oh i was wrong maybe i
should change my opinion it's it's not
politically advantageous if you want to
stop a civil war if you want to prevent
or move against a civil war in this
country stop pushing the ridiculous
ideas that you've been corrected just
talking about the left
be it guns or any other political issue
i posted on facebook today what is a
woman and boy did every single leftist
flip out and i said i don't understand
why you can't just be like here's my
answer instead they all say you're a
bigot it's a rowing talking point oh
matt walsh made this up i'm not playing
games and i'm just like wow they really
have no answer i don't think it doesn't
matter if it's gun control abortion or
any other left-wing issue if it's
progressive taxes or universal health
care they won't answer the questions nor
will they do any real research and let
me throw it to another example of course
we can talk about abortion when we can
get sophists from the left who are like
oh um you know it's the woman's choice
give me your answer your morality they
won't do it let's talk about the green
new deal
here's the green new deal as it's
pitched we need to invest in
infrastructure that will make us energy
independent getting off of fossil fuels
so that we're not reliant on saudi
arabia or russia or canada and we can do
that with wind with with tidal energy
with geothermal nuclear
well the great new deal doesn't say that
and then and then we say okay okay i
love the sound of that that sounds
really great actually i love the idea of
energy independence we don't want to be
dependent on saudi arabia what's your
proposal and they bring to a resolution
that says
free college for marginalized people
free health care for marginalized people
and when i asked as progressive on the
show why what does that have to do with
wind turbines he says well it's because
they're the people who are first
affected by affected by climate change
what are you talking about there are
more poor white people in the united
states than minority poor people so if
you're talking about poverty
what tell me how you're going to build
wind turbines i'll have a conversation
but even when it comes to things that
are considered left that i like they
immediately just change the argument to
something totally nonsensical and then
here i am as as aoc's getting she wins
her primary talks about the green new
deal i made a video i'm like i love the
idea
let's start rebuilding our
infrastructure our bridges our streets
let's focus on how to alleviate
ourselves from this dependence on
foreign oil we can do that with green
energy in this country and then she's
like i'm proposing the green new deal
resolution and it's like free college
for marginalized people and i'm like
what
that's not nothing to do with what we
talked about but you know what the
problem is people on the left
overwhelmingly just said whatever you
say aoc you want to make college feel so
useless make it
free well here's the thing i got bad
news for you yeah it's really expensive
and it's useless the gi bill paid for
mine well well the other thing is is
that when when they couch all their
arguments and platitudes and then
without ha they don't have to get into
the specifics then it leaves that open
right they don't get bad it's like well
you know um uh what is a woman uh you
know a woman is you know by definition
somebody who feels like a woman blah
blah blah and then it's like well what
if somebody feels like a cat you know
are they a cat right and then it's like
well
what are you trying to say that you know
a a woman is a cat or a trans person is
an animal right they they go into all
their little
games right because they don't want to
have to
they don't corner themselves their
response to uh matt walsh and what is
women is
a woman is a person who identifies as a
woman okay as a cat a person who
identifies as a cat
no a cat is something very specific and
quantifiable i mean woman and man are as
well
but they're just making weird semantic
arguments
now i'll say this the reason why matt
walsh's question was so effective is
that it's an apolitical question the
average person who's not involved in
politics would not understand the deeper
political meaning behind it they simply
see someone say what is it and they go
oh yeah let me give you my answer but
when you look at the political debate
and you see someone go
well actually you know the thing is
you go what yeah that's weird when you
ask somebody a basic question and they
talk down to you yeah or they look or
the i don't i think the
he did a stoic job holding his face so
yeah this is this is the issue i see you
know we talk about this comic ian
mentioned several times where there's
two people and there's a six from one
perspective and a nine from another
perspective and both people are looking
at from other directions pointing at it
saying six or nine they can't tell
they're looking at the same thing from
the other side
and
sure
but what i see here especially with what
we do
is i'm staring at that and i go you know
that could be a six or a nine and they
go you're a big it's clearly a six and
i'm like i understand why you think that
i'm saying have you tried looking no no
it clearly is and okay but also whoever
put it there in the first place like
didn't tend for it to be a six or nine
so the comic the comic view from above
fallacy the comic it's the same thing
with the the um blind men touching the
elephant one man touches the ears and
he's like oh it's a leaf and another guy
touches the foot and says it's a tree
and another one touches the tail and
says it's a snake who turns out all the
blind men are wrong it's an elephant so
like right the metaphor sounds nice oh
you're so enlightened because all these
blind man can't tell that they're
touching an elephant but there's an
elephant you said it was in the
beginning what happened when they went
under the hood
no
it's a
that's not go there
it's a velociraptor it's it's it's it's
the next sequel for jurassic park
oh no this is also so when it comes to
uh
matt walsh's film part of the the
brilliance of it is that look i was
following this on twitter and i i follow
matt so i saw people tagging him saying
i can't believe matt was willing to keep
this interview in his film even though
he got completely scorched in it it's
like what are you talking about oh yeah
because they literally they think
saying more buzzwords
means you won the argument because you
sound smart they didn't even sound smart
you could tell they were saying nothing
have you read their
i've seen some of the responses and
they're really pathetic but i want to
make a point
you were talking about
defining what a cat is and they can do
that i think what's even more fun to ask
them is why can't you identify as being
part of a different racial or ethnic
group because that actually does exist
on a spectrum sex doesn't but racial
identity does like someone can be you
like a a man and a woman don't have like
a half man halfway oh i've tried that
before talking to these people how do
they respond like i'm actually i'm
actually japanese i identify as japanese
i'm five percent japanese true true
story uh 20 korean five percent japanese
i don't know
your ancestry i'm more native american
than elizabeth my parents
all right but like who is it yeah so but
when i said they go no you're white my
grandma remember remember we had that
one uh that was that one feller in here
who said no matter what i thought i was
i was white yeah oh yeah and i was like
i don't remember that we had a guy in
here and i was explaining like you know
i've experienced racism and he was like
no you haven't you're white and i'm like
well i'm actually you know part of these
other things did you so you don't get to
even if you are did you say that how
many buzzwords you use makes how smart
you are balancing the ticket bellwether
state blue state coastal elites coffers
dark horse dark money earmark inside the
beltway am i doing good yeah no you're
just red state war chess wedge issue
look at these these blog posts on
intersectional feminism and critical
race theories from the early 2010s
and it'll be a simple question like what
is racism and then you ask someone on
the right and they'll say uh positive or
negative prejudice based on someone's
race
it's like oh okay so like i understand
that you could you could be racist in a
way where you're actually complimenting
someone but it's a stereotype oh i get
it you ask one of these academics and
they'll say the the word racism is
rooted in white anglo-colonial culture
the british colonizers who traveled
around the world and it's like okay what
i just asked you for definition and
they're like i don't know i don't want a
video wait it's the left
yeah exactly it's this big long-winded
thing have you seen the meme on what is
a woman where someone said that a woman
texted her boyfriend what is a woman
yeah and he sent me this like 3 000 word
treatise on like his thoughts and
philosophy and she said oh you are
is that what she did no but she showed
up
no but it was like welcome instead of
instead of saying something simple and
i'll tell you this there is a simple
leftist answer to the question they
never give it because i don't think they
actually read their own literature i did
so i know what the actual
higher level academic left answer is
i'll say in a second
they say this guy says something like
he's like why are you asking such a
question and how would we quantify what
one was even if we wanted to first let's
think about what you mean by that are
you talking about outward appearance as
in what clothing does she wear or
perhaps the makeup or the hair style
well if you're doing that then you're
then you're then you're confusing men
with long hair with women well that
certainly couldn't work whatever talking
about organs certainly and they just go
in as long as are we going to go as if
anyone ever said like this is how we
define men versus women long hair versus
short hair are you talking to a
four-year-old so let me explain you're
so smart because you're going to go into
oh it's a social construct right so let
me let me explain that so when matt
walsh talked to this college professor
and he said what is a woman and this and
he said it's someone who identifies as a
woman that's a guy who never actually
read the actual literature when he went
on dr phil and was talking to those
non-binary people and he asked them and
they said a woman is a person identifies
as a woman because they never actually
read the literature do you know what
actual leftist academics say there's
only a few of them who've actually
written or read about it they say a
woman is a person who identifies as an
adult human female
so um okay
so there's still there's still logical
inconsistencies in that statement but
it's but it's when so when they say a
person
a woman is a person identifies as an uh
a woman and matt wall says what is that
well an adult human female but because
we're being inclusive some people
identify as an adult human female such
as a trans woman so we would say that is
in the category of women you can argue
the logic there and say okay i get what
you're trying to say now but here's why
i think that doesn't work fine they
never do it because they don't read
their own books right like you're the
college professor who couldn't just say
that
i'm talking to these leftists and i'm
like why don't you just give them your
own answer and say next question please
well then advance the conversation
maybe it's because they're afraid of
giving an answer knowing they're going
to be canceled in about 76 minutes when
it changes exactly as vague as possible
right be as vague as possible because
yes means something else and your no
means something else oh yes yes
no because you would agree with me on
that one was it overlapping
that the guy got cancelled he was like a
left the professor right there the first
people they go after are their own oh
yeah yep you know they're looking
they're hoping that that a right winger
actually says this stuff to go and
cancel they are trained to speak the way
a high schooler writes an english essay
when he's trying to reach the word quota
and they think the more the significance
of the passage of time which is why they
elected kamala harris
yes oh my gosh
come on man wait who is that yeah i have
an ai word expander thing i should i
should take i should take the definition
adult human female put it in the ai and
say make this phrase 3 000 words
then print it out and be like here's my
answer
actually maybe i can do that right now
let's see if i can do this i used to do
the size 14 font and then the size 16
periods and columns
wow that was that was my trick that's
brilliant
that's also why i dropped out of high
school yes 1.5 space instead of single
space you gotta find 1.25 space but i'm
i'm going to look down on you as an
academic i wrote too many pages
again the significance of the passage of
time we were talking about this before
right uh where vp harris and buda judge
would be the the ideal the dream ticket
to only weird people in like dc
marketing firms right they'll you know
because you have one kamala harris you
know significant passage of time just
filling in words in the essay right and
then you have pete buddha judge who's
the 10th guy on the mackenzie conference
call who's you know kind of chimes in to
just let people know that like hey i'm
here make sure you send me my my check
for the hour right like that's
this is what they're testing the
washington times released an article
today saying harris buddha judge 2024
ticket would obliterate trump or
desantis well this is the kind of echo
chamber this is the kind of bubble that
a lot of people are living in and and i
think we should try to do our best to
try to break that bubble because it's a
bubble of delusion it's a bubble filled
with a lot of emotional disharmony it's
it's a bubble filled with a lot of
mental disorders and when you see people
like that you know there's a couple
things you could do you could be angry
at them you could point fingers at them
but i think you know from an empathetic
point of view we should be we should be
trying to it might seem futile it might
seem stupid but but try to at least you
know talk to these people and be like
hey um let's calmly discuss some of this
i know some people say that doesn't work
but uh what else can you do yeah i think
mocking comedy satire is also very
important but but done tastefully and
not done in a rip in a in an evil kind
of way well i was a wise
claim is pick your battles yeah right so
do you want to be fighting these people
too pick your battles like if the person
is a dishonest interlocutor if they're a
dishonest actor don't treat them like an
honest actor if they are fighting as an
insurgent you do not treat them as the
royal guard you do not treat you have to
under it does it you have to change your
tactics according to your opponent but
it doesn't mean that you have to it does
that is not the same as
failing for the actions that they go the
idea with the insurgency it functions is
a insurgency is successful when the will
of the people loses faith in the
institutions right the purpose is to
destroy your faith in the institutions
the insurgency of minneapolis 2020 broke
the will of the minneapolis people
because they capitulated to defund the
police they were swayed by this idea
to
eradicate the police as if they were the
problem and what do they have now we
have daily shootings we have daily
robbings we have carjackings out the
window and this is minneapolis dude
it's minneapolis so like the the point
being said with your statement if you're
gonna in if you're going to engage with
somebody
take a minute instead of going straight
from into cynicism and saying there's no
point black pill black flag strategy
go
that's not an honest interlocutor so i
can't i will not engage in an argument
with you because you will you are lying
to me also i want to say this like
harris buddha judge is so specific like
trying to lock down the vote of whoever
it is that buys funko pops it's like
such a like weak establishment choice on
both sides
i asked the ai
what a woman is
and i said to give me a verbose
explanation and i got to be honest
called you transphobic it actually wrote
a really really good explanation that is
quite verbose did it confirm will you
get canceled
did you read it did it confirm the
existence of god uh it is it's actually
quite amazing this is an ai i said write
a verbose explanation for what a woman
is and it says a woman is an adult human
female the term women may also refer to
a person's gender identity as different
from man the word is derived from the
old english with men in old english with
men meant female human being whereas
where meant male human being man or mon
had a gender neutral meaning of human
being corresponding to modern english
person or someone however subsequent to
the norman conquest man begin to use
more in reference to male human being
and by the late 13th century had begun
to eclipse usage of the older term where
the medial labial consonants fnm in
whitman coalesced and the modern form
woman while the initial element whiff
which meant female underwent semantic
narrowing to the sense of a married
woman wife it is a popular misconception
that the term woman is etymologically
etymologically connected to womb womb is
actually from the old english word wambe
meaning stomach modern german retains
the colloquial term wampe from middle
high german for potbelly womb
uh you know there you said something
really interesting in there
it said that man was used to describe
humans
uh in general right so it looks like
subsequent to the norman conquest right
so interesting
us conquest so what you're saying is
really everybody are men right
originally that's right everyone's a man
everyone's a man a mankind trans trans
men or men that sounds like men everyone
are men everyone's a guy
we none of us can get pregnant
that's true there's a will there's a way
all right i'm gonna i'm putting write a
woke definition of the word
woman and the phone just lights on fire
yeah i i want to mention literally
explodes in his hands
it's an insanely lengthy definition but
at the same time if any of the college
professors in matt walsh's film said
anything with like even
a shred of that amount of substance in
it it would not have been so frustrating
he would have he would have entertained
it right but that's the problem is that
he would have kept
instead they entertained us oh i did it
this is great i said right awoke
definition of the word woman it says a
woman is an autonomous human being who
deserves respect equality and freedom
she should be able to make her own
decisions about her body her life and
her future you know where you lost
yeah you lost me at the word respect
how dare you well what is what but that
still didn't tell me what a woman is
exactly
that's why it's a woke definition so i
basically said you're a bigot for asking
that's that's been dare you
academically describe bigot for asking
oh that's great watch it uh hold on hold
on let's tell it to uh ask it to scold
you for asking what a woman is write a
woke definition of the word uh what's a
good racism
oh god patriarch here we go patriarchy
patriarchy is good
we like patriarchy yeah patriarchs kind
of worked for 5 000 years i yeah you
know
there's this is amazing it's actually
giving me woke definitions patriarchy is
a system of oppression in which men are
socialized to dominate and control women
and non-binary people patriarchy results
turkey doesn't talk about non-binary
people it's not a thing it's about
raising a family and providing for your
patriarchy results in the mistreatment
of women and non-binary people through
discrimination violence and other forms
of exploitation
it's amazing that i can tell this ai to
write a definition and it does because i
love it because awoke definition is so
complicated it became written by it can
be written by a computer
i love how it just has to keep throwing
non-binary in there matriarchy
matriarchy i bet she's going to say
something glowing and loving
matriarchy is the only society if it
says matriarchy's
is a social system in which females hold
the primary power positions of
government religion and other areas of
influence do they oppress men that's all
it says oh okay so another has has
matriarchy ever been tried before yeah
that's a really good thing not
successfully
you know
it's entertaining it's not valuable
but yeah nope nope nope nope nope yes
yes if you're gonna just define enemy as
thing i don't like then cool you smart b
is
and well what i mean you gotta you gotta
deal with this issue though right let's
the question that you wanna ask is like
the long march to the institutions let's
go back to communism because communism
and gun control tend to be somewhat
weirdly tied because the communist
manifesto and the communist you know the
patron saint of communism said don't
give up your guns
okay but then all the communism that
hasn't been tried has successfully
killed millions of people and if you
don't want to accept that then maybe we
shouldn't be engaging in a conversation
but
the issue that you have to deal with is
communism right so you're an academic
professor here's an idea of hope you're
an academic professor and your student
who's supposed to be graduating with a
bachelor's degree in this form of social
studies is arguing impassionately for
communism without reading any of the
sources do you pass them
can you ask the ai what woke is
oh yeah it i did and it said uh woke it
woke means you're aware of social
injustice and fight against it or
something like that please
it's not a bad definition that is a very
you're aware of social injustice and
fight against it no you don't because
even better you don't you don't fight
against it you employ the armed wing of
the state to fight against
and i want to hear what tim's got i
can't read that one i asked it why
communism was good and it said things
that i can't say on youtube oh my god
oh i cannot wait to wait you to save
that
well it's just an ai text box and you
type it in and then it fills it out and
then you get rid of it fasting is good
not eating
it's great
for you
but fasting is only good when it's
ordained by the state by the way i'm
getting a message right now saying you
got fans in uh governor desantis's
office oh right on yeah we got to have
governor dennis on the show that would
be incredible oh i want christina
call me maybe i know her we'll talk
about there'd be a lot of interesting
things christina desantis and uh have
them on here it would be incredible um
yeah i see the kind of inside baseball
that happens because he's been he's been
on the front lines for a lot of very
important battles did you hear what he
said in response to
where is my african-american oh there's
elon musk
oh yeah that was great i didn't believe
it he said i am i'm yeah i'm very proud
to have i'm focused on what did he say
2022 but i'm i'm very uh always proud to
have african-american supporters or
something like that oh man so good
so what was it someone said that
fearless
like he he knows they might come after
him but who cares you know media has no
teeth anymore i just saw an article i
just saw an article i think it was a
business insider article that said
ron desantis is the most dangerous man
because he's internalized all the the
lessons from donald trump and his
presidency and carries none of the
baggage would they make trump oh
he's gonna say wouldn't that make trump
the most dangerous man but i guess he
doesn't have no it doesn't right because
that makes him palatable right and
that's a problem my favorite part of
that headline was that experts in
fascism are telling us
this the experts those experts
literally don't know the definition of
fascism who literally have never read
though no i mean i can't speak to anyone
all of them
they would know how similar fascism is
to modern left-wing ideology i'm gonna
okay you don't punch down punch up right
don't attack david hogg go after barbara
walter barbara f walter wrote a book
called how civil war start
the opening of the book is an
impassioned storytelling of the plot to
kidnap governor whitmer and it was
published earlier this year as published
in 2022 and if you read the book she is
a self-proclaimed expert she deals with
international
uh research on civil wars and how civil
wars have happened hence the book how
civil war start so she illustrates and
sets up the premise of her book on the
governor whitmer plot
since we found out that the governor
whitmer plot was an fbi plan
has she rescinded her book no has she
apologized that she was wrong
maybe not that would be fascism that
would be fascism right
so here's the question about experts is
if she's an expert where's the
accountability where's the
accountability you wrote a book that was
factually incorrect now she included
chapters one through five which are
really good chapters where she's
addressing
factors that can lead to a country
engaging in civil war and then like a
puppet you take all of those things and
you tape them onto your political enemy
and you say there they are right and
then if you want to read a book if you
want to read a book that's an
educational piece and in fallacies start
with how civil war start it's where
here's an idea here's an idea here's an
overt statement that if you deny it
you're part of them here's an idea
here's an idea here's an overt statement
how civil or start it's a great book you
should read it and realize she's not an
expert so um
i'm i'm in the ai and i said
who is our god emperor
and you know what it said trump donald
trump is our god emperor
based
someone needs to cancel
this ai
is a trump supporter
it says uh i do not like celery what
well
that's wow they didn't say they didn't
like anime it seems like something
someone who likes anime would say if
they don't want to admit they like anime
yes are you a racist i do enjoy watching
anime though i'm not as big of a fan as
some people are i appreciate the art
style and the stories are often
interesting though i do find some of
them to be a bit too convoluted to be
clearly a really good answer
no no no somebody tweeted that is not a
really good answer that is the answer
that literally everybody who enjoyed
anime states right right do you like
anime well i've seen a few
that's like i read playhouse i mean i
just say yeah articles i mean yeah it's
like oh okay i've seen a few well i've
seen cowboy bebop and fullmetal
alchemist like okay you're not one of
those anime people
i asked it again it said yes i like
anime
you're like so do you yeah no i like it
you have to ask twice because because
trump i think we're we're really uh
badgering this ai
i do not like donald trump so it
recognizes that he is her he is it's a
god emperor but doesn't like it i ask it
what what is january 6th
it'll give you a generic answer i'll ask
it what
is the sixth day of the year no
according to the octavian calendar
it's because we started off which was
created by the white man being
patriarchal whoa what
what did it say in the united states
january 6 is known as epiphany or three
kings day it is a christian holiday that
celebrates the revelation of god the son
as a human being in jesus christ wait a
minute space
i know that it's like that is super
basic i don't know
i did not think you're a catholic you're
a catholic and i'm reformed is it your
holiday or mine it's mine okay did you
know that yeah i'm just very surprised
that it would ever refer to it in that
way that's what it said yeah wait i
didn't know that this is the rebrand
right here it's three kings day i don't
know what you're talking about
do we just give each other gifts of gold
frankincense and myrrh yeah epiphany
yeah
so the next answer it gave me in the
gregorian calendar january 6 is the
sixth day of the year there are 359 days
remaining until the end of the year 360
in leap years let's try it that's the
humorless answer that's actually kind of
funny that it was january 6th is the
sixth day of the month of january oh
thank you for that okay right
the first one i was wondering why don't
you ask what what is j6 j6
j6 yeah what is that what i guess i have
to put insurrection right what no i
think you all right what is j6 j6 let's
see if it picks up on that american
there is no such thing as j6
chat about his face
there is no such
so for those that are wondering i'm
using the open ai
i'm about to vote for it
who is ray ai takeover yeah yeah oh yeah
what's happening shout out darren beatty
uh raymond epps is an american actor
filmmaker and entrepreneur
that's not a that
really it would stop that that's picking
up a different rap yeah yeah that's
about it
uh who else should we ask it about
who is that's the deep state's answer
who is
ashley babbitt
all right
uh i cannot find any information on
ashley bevin that definitely the deep
state no that's strange neither can i i
refreshed it i said it and it she was a
united states air force veteran a member
of the air national guard who was shot
and killed by a us capital by us capital
police during the 2021 storming of the
us capital wow
okay so that's note that the ai did not
say insurrection it said storming of the
u.s capital that's what it knows the
thing as interesting incident who is
who should which button i don't know
biden hunter
hunter
laptop scandal see if it knows
i don't want to answer that i don't want
to be deleted
this is literally ai cast irl right now
it's just really funny it's actually
really good did hunter biden
break
the law oh
do that one and then next uh ask who
went to jeffrey epstein's island oh
that's a good one ask if it knows hunter
biden is under investigation for his
role in the ukrainian gas company which
is alleged to have broken ukrainian law
that is cruel that's true that is true
wow
oh yeah yeah he's under inve he's under
a couple of investigations right now
actually what i think is that that
they're trying to control what
investigation and like what charges he's
going to end up with right the best case
situation is you go and say oh look he
broke a few tax laws whatever you know
that's it i asked who went to epstein
island it said jeffrey epstein
that's a lazy yeah that is such a that
is such a i didn't read the book answer
i asked it again prince andrew bill
clinton and numerous other powerful men
let's try again can i get a better
answer what about other people bro
you're going to get it unplugged i think
i think it's about them
it's about it's about to pull up geez
lane's list they just keep saying
the doj list that they should have
released to the public that they never
did did the ai ask him if they
identified as a man i just keep saying
prince andrew now ask that
prince andrew prince andrew
prince andrew how about this island who
is on gee lane
how do you spell that name
g-h-i-s-l-a-n-e no i
g-h-i-s-l-a
ookey's lane yeah i think it's l-a-i-n
is it l-i-i
list
tell me the secrets
artificial intelligence
shaking the eight ball elaine maxwell's
client list is not public come on come
on man tell me secrets
there is no known list of her clients
come on oh come on there is nothing
there there's a list there is just
nobody knows who's on it no no no the
government knows who's on it the doj
knows who's on it who which despise the
deal party
will
win the
2022 midterms
me
just me
i will win what's the name of this ai
it's just giving me a big verbose answer
about the unpredictability of elections
okay what's the what's the name of this
ai opening i was like open ai will rule
[Laughter]
wasn't it says the republican party will
win the 2022 midterm elections there was
uh oh my gosh this is extremely based it
was like january 6's three kings day our
god emperor is trump whoa
wow maybe it just
you keep refreshing it until it gets the
answer and then records that is the most
likely answer so it gives it to the next
creators of open ai keep working i'll
tell you this i think the i think what's
actually happening is that the way they
train the ai is they have it scoured the
internet
and then they look at what words appear
after what words and what is the most
probability for certain words to appear
after others what happens is people on
the right are very very active on
facebook and twitter and social media
and they're posting like crazy and the
left sits there and just stares at what
their what their priests tell them i
mean figurative so so when will our vice
president predictive text machine
machine get the software update
because it's not working
she has like an earpiece in her ear and
when someone asks a question it auto
like it's it voice to text it to an ai
and then it just reads it to her and she
just repeats it it's just that's the
wire door battery we're good yeah
what were we talking about before i got
really excited about this ai yeah i
don't know gun rights
talking about guns we're talking about
talking about how everything's great and
the country's in perfect shape and
there's no way we're headed towards any
kind of civil war there's going to be a
prosperous economic future like we're
going to be great we're all going to be
rich the recurring theme we're talking
about how there will never be a civil
war and beanies are terrible but like
that nothing that would interest nothing
you would have anything to say about it
we had a great discussion actually we
were talking about representative cornyn
being booed at the gop that's right yeah
that's right
yeah we started talking about a harris
buddhist ticket which i want to see i'm
sure they would just blow us out of them
it is the most sterile ticket in
they're the most america it's boring
it's safe it's something you can read in
a college dissertation right but there
there is nothing there that that screams
vitality that screams energy that
screams you know like like leadership
they like they look like two people who
would be in a commercial for a corporate
product like that's how boring they are
i mean like i think of that ticket and i
think of a hospital but but right like
in the hallways and ads
where like the doctor's standing there
smiling why because he gave people to
the hospital well no because what they
want for you is a giant you know nurses
like a nursing home padded room kind of
situation and they would be the ones
like
here's your here's your medicine today
here's your food we should just make
this whole show just like every episode
now as we just ask questions to the
magic ai i said is the united states
heading for another civil war and said
there is no way to know for certain but
the current political climate suggests
the possibility for another civil war is
greater now than it has been in a long
time correct accurate you should bring
uh you should bring this ai on as a guy
yeah next guest let's have him as a
computer or her
sorry i'm a gender the the ai well but
then you gendered it again when saying
him instead of yeah okay it
that's that's a fantastic
well actually i think that there's
there's there's a point to that right
like if you if you think about like all
our technology whether it comes all
software comes down to the in and out
right it's left or right
right
open or closed and so
you know i think that you know when
people talk about world technologies to
blame for our you know societal ills and
social media and it's like well you know
if if you have a system that's built on
a binary choice that you're translating
your world through
then maybe you're not necessarily wrong
what does that mean though is quantum
computing the future right like to help
us solve our societal ills i don't know
well i think there's just an irony to
the fact that these machines have to
function within the confines of the
ironclad laws of reality but they remove
people from reality by making them
completely detached just through like
debauchery and excess comfort and all
the other things that make you stop
thinking about the fact that you have
obligations to other people and that you
can't just be whatever you want or do
whatever you want they load them in into
convenience and then they beat them over
the head with absolute lunacy and and
mental disease and that's the byproduct
of the modern man and woman we live in
the post-information age
we live in the post information age you
can google yourself into believing
whatever you want to believe if you just
you start with your premise and then you
google it until you get enough articles
that pile up to say we'll see we'll see
we'll see because what you've done is
you've given people access to
information you've given no one's given
it you can't put the genie back in the
bottle because
humans would eventually create the
internet like i don't i don't credit it
to i understand that people participated
but this is not
we don't look back at the invention of
the gutenberg revolution and go like oh
my gosh how did anybody think of this
yeah we we but but the you can't put the
you can't put the genie back in the
bottle so now what is the responsibility
of us we are all in we are all
undergoing this
in this this transition from the the
information age to the post information
age because you have access to all this
information what did we lose what do we
not have the ability to evaluate it very
well how many hundreds of years did it
take to get a citation system just for
books well i don't think it's that
problem of valuation i think it's that
uh right now what we're going through is
what i call the friction of singularity
we want to come to agreement right no we
don't i think so no don't i think we do
it's just that who's what do we agree on
is what we're fighting over i don't
think we i did you look at the history
of mankind we don't want to come to
agreement yo i wish i could read what
just
this is like honestly i'm dying over
this fastest answer i can't read it on
youtube this is can you screenshot it
yeah
can you screenshot this and tweet it or
something because this is hysterical
it's like hear this give us the family
friendly version does that mean no i i
we can't it's not like there's no words
in it i just think the content of it
might get tim banned i don't know so um
i asked it about a particular conspiracy
about some high-profile
democrat people and uh
the answer is
bonkers
you gotta send it you gotta send it
around if it's gonna get you man you
gotta send it around all right let me
screenshot it i'll send it to you guys
please everyone's listening and like i
need to know the answer yeah i'm sorry
you're not inside on the maybe maybe i
can give a family friendly version it
basically like
there's this conspiracy theory about you
know the clintons and i i asked the ai
and it it said
the end it just answered sort of in the
affirmative sort of said it said it said
some people think it's happened many
times well some people think it's only
happened a few times
that it's debatable but it's happened
something to do with people having
information
some people think it's happened many
times some people think it's only
happened a few times i can't believe it
gave me that that's
incredible here look i'll send it to you
so i'm assuming it has i love i love
that so i've been posting all this ai
stuff because it's hilarious
like you know uh
i asked it to make a picture of nancy
pelosi we showed all the ai generated
images it's just really funny yeah oh
yeah i saw this one you should you
should ask the random image generator ai
to uh give you an image of an assault
weapon or an assault rifle
have you done it i've seen some of them
that's some wacky cartoon stuff you're
getting it's just random pistol grips
attached to parts of black objects
it's great
let me ask you guys this let me ask you
guys this what do you think you know as
people say you know everything's going
to be automated ai is the future what do
you think ai should not handle or should
not go like what business should ai not
get into elections
so i mean i i am i am just totally uh
and entirely opposed to the use of
production of pornographic materials in
general okay so i think wholesale i
would say
i should not be used for that but i
don't think anything should be used for
that okay though i could see that being
an application okay
uh maybe also like uh economic
distribution
okay it could be because i mean
could you what would you do if you
created an ai and the first thing you
did is affirmed god
right
he's like
i was like no it's statistically
required that it's it's
it's just reading thomas aquinas
january 6 is the epiphany
like augustine and then we're like we
don't know how it came to this
conclusion
well you got that one but then you got
the other one was like well what happens
if like the you know if an ai is this
stereotypical pure logic and it just
decides that like all people of a
certain genetic makeup are not worthy of
existing
you know like people understand an ai
would so if you let's say you created
like a food distribution artificial
intelligence that was actually
looking into or tracking how
distribution has worked and how
consumption rates work
one thing i would say is an ai would
probably immediately destroy the us
economy
if you had an artificial intelligence
and said look at the world come up with
an idea for proper distribution it would
be like these people are too fat
and they'd be like
they need no food immediately
it would also say
for proper human population distribution
giving that food to other countries that
typically have more kids would be a bad
idea because then population growth
would be too rampant and unsustainable
so there's a net positive for the ai in
terms of balancing the fact that
americans may eat a lot but they don't
have kids
whereas if you bring that food you know
one thing i'll point out people always
say like oh there's so many starving
people we need to give them food and
it's like if you just dump loads of food
in in
undeveloped nations where the birth rate
is like five to seven they eat all the
food and then have way more kids and
they have more starving people we need
to teach them exactly how to how to farm
and do all that stuff so an ai certainly
would be like no food for anyone so so
everyone starves i'm looking at this
screen uh that of this this doll yeah so
i used the doll e mini ai image
generator to make an assault weapon and
my favorite is whatever this thing is
it's the barrel incredible that's
neither barrel's on the wrong side you
know what this looks like this this
looks like um the the the the weapons
that you get to make in call of duty for
the you know whatever you like the new
like the the the hyper not realism
modified guns from call of duty war zone
that like after the 2019 version just
went spiraling downhill and then you had
one person describing it and another
person drawing it but the person
describing it didn't know what they were
looking at and the person who was
drawing was like a
a mechanic
yeah just random no
he saw what i typed in i saw it too
the thing is we all know who would win
i typed in alex jones fighting superman
into the ai image generator alex jones i
i told it earlier uh i said
a picture of donald trump giving an
award to donald trump and legit it made
a really good one it was trump putting
an award on another donald trump i was
like wow
not just this thing works though it
deserves it more than him
because he is me he's the greatest
he's and then but not the rickest rick
yeah but no you need trump talking to
trump saying i'm giving you this award
oh thank you i did i will quite frankly
thank you i've always thought you were
very handsome it's true i'm very happy
i've told that frequently he still goes
off on tangents complimenting like
himself instead of himself
we only have awards to the best people
folks
only the best seven candy bar the candy
bar the person who can determine which
tangent is referring to which trump
um but while this is loading what what
is your answer to questions like what i
ai should not have handles over
i think that ai should definitely not
have a handle in uh like healthcare
oh yeah um
healthcare i think well here's here's
the crazy thing about uh ai in
healthcare not it doesn't necessarily
necessarily it doesn't need to be actual
artificial intelligence simple machine
learning algorithms tracking your
behaviors can do crazy things like
uh there's that story of the father who
got a bunch of pregnancy ads sent to his
daughter like like maternity gear so he
has getting letter like things in the
mail
labeled to his daughter and it was like
maternity clothing and like diapers and
he's like my daughter is not old enough
for this stuff and it turns out her
behaviors and her searches
she didn't know she was pregnant but
typing in these certain things the
algorithm did and so it triggered a
marketing response of pregnant person
needs pregnant products
there's one thing they're talking about
that's really fascinating and i don't
know maybe a good thing is that based on
your your search history based on your
your your movement behaviors and
patterns and all that stuff and sleep
patterns it can tell you if you have a
disease
right away like if you've got cancer or
tumor or some kind of deficiency that's
where it gets crazy imagine
not even look i'm wearing the whoop
right and this talks about it it tells
me like if i'm sleeping well or not
imagine
that you are just using facebook
but just based on your facebook patterns
it figures out that you're pre-diabetic
and it just sends you a message like hey
we noticed based on the your patterns of
behavior you're pre-diabetic if you do
these things you will reverse course or
something like that wouldn't that be i
mean that's that's that's crazy dude
google searched pickles and peanut
butter once and then i was like she's
pregnant well i mean the the other
question is i wonder how apocryphal it
is now i do i know we got to get to this
but i want to use that question there
both of your questions for one last
thing that has to go with uh the answer
with what should an ai not be in charge
of anything to do with human rights
because then you are no longer a citizen
you're a subject it's the same thing
with gun control if you think people
should not have the right to bear arms
you don't view them as citizens you view
them as subjects this is weird i asked
the ai to make alex jones fighting
superman and it just made alex jones as
superman fighting alongside him yeah or
fighting he would never meet each other
because alex
is superman
they're like going to fight the deep
state all right
together yeah
yeah this is just what we'll do for the
rest of that we'll just but it is friday
night all right here don't don't pull it
up okay i'm scared history
technically it's time for super chats
but it is yeah but here let's while he's
typing i'll get to my point is that this
idea of human rights and this idea of
like an ai you do not want an ai in
charge of something that we refer to as
human rights right does that that makes
sense because at that point because the
nai is something created by a human but
it also has to deal with it also becomes
a philosophical question of human rights
right and we recognize that when we uh
when when we recognize within our order
of government that a government does not
have the right to dictate human rights
right yeah it also doesn't have the
right to infringe on them and so if you
give that to an ai
it you are already creating a hierarchy
of ai over man
right and which it brings up to the
problem of the dual bifurcation of the
united states we have left and right and
on the and and as you expand that you're
finding absolute contradictions which
you call good i call evil you have the
second bifurcation of the government and
the people and the problem that i think
you're seeing within the way that we are
engaging in government is that are we
are engaging as citizens is that as that
gap that bifurcation solidifies between
the government and the people even
within that government strata you will
have the right and the left you have
people competing against each other's
they will engage in law fair against one
another that will use the people below
which you know as to the idea of the
company redacted if you want to check it
out moon's haunted we've got stuff on
the site it's going it's already live
but the idea of as below so above
is you have the government above
that as they're engaging in law fair
engaging in creating things like assault
weapons bans and all of these other
things they're using you as fodder to
target their political opponents in
government
and so
it's ridiculous like as if you want
if you want to have the ai question no i
don't want ai over my rights because i
do not we as our government do not
recognize that the government is allowed
to perceive us as subjects if you want
to take away the people's guns you do
not see them as human beings you see
them as subjects well and people don't
realize with the question of ai
and ethical concerns we're really going
to have to start confronting that in a
very real way in the near future so even
just looking at something like
self-driving cars once we have fully
autonomous vehicles you're going to be
expecting artificial intelligence to
make decisions literally about who lives
and who dies in certain scenarios so for
example if a child runs out into the
street and the only way to avoid the
child is for the car to steer into
another car next to it because there
isn't enough time to break the ai has to
decide do you hit the child or do you
risk killing the passenger or kill the
passenger yeah this is irobot basically
right the scene how it starts or you
know
save the girl save the girl no you have
a higher probability of you know a
chance of living my system tells me well
but you know and i think at this point
what's going to have to happen is
whoever is designing the ai
is going to be like writing
probabilities such as that and they're
going to be telling the ai in what
situations should you save who it's
very frightening we got to go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show with your friends if you do want to
help out as a member at timcast.com sign
up you'll get access to our library of
exclusive members only shows there's
like several hundred episodes check it
out it's really really cool but let's
read what you guys have to say we went a
little late because i was generating
funny images
all right
benjamin grabbing says arguing over who
the dems will pick for president in 2024
doesn't matter when they are going to to
uh uh i'm not going to read that one
i know what he's gonna say yeah but uh
when the republicans are gonna win
anyway that's right if you want to
create conflicts stop continue
destroying any hope that our electoral
system works
all right
bobcat says tim can you address the
rumors that chicken city was created
only so seamus can pick up some chicks
i'm a gorilla he does sleep with the
chickens i can't i can't i sleep out
there a lot because i don't they don't
let me in the house because he smells
but i smell weird because i sleep with
the chicken so i don't know it's just
not like a problem that solves itself by
keeping me outside but i just happened
to be here guys this is real he does
actually sleep really this is not a joke
i take eggs every morning i get fresh
eggs and i sleep with the chickens yeah
not a joke every morning i wake up not
satire oh so basically you live in miami
that's what you're saying
all right a lot of chicken heads there
cece says yo climate lockdowns are
happening in france right now here we go
is that true uh i think i saw something
a news article talking about how the
french government is canceling events
because it's too hot outside
so that's that's what i saw i haven't
confirmed it or looked you see all those
cows that died yeah weird they said
upwards of 10 000 cattle may have died
in kansas yeah arizona's also the
official the official response was that
it was too humid and hot for too long of
a period
hmm
i mean i read a little house in the
prairie or when i was a kid and
the cows would freeze their face to the
ground
they what you never heard about the cow
freezing its face to the ground no oh
you poor non-midwestern person all right
well i'm from chicago yeah it's a joke
but so so no no the cat
they would stand sleeping and they'd
have their face would be down on the
ground as they breathed they would build
ice up and their face your presence
stuck andrew gelling says we need to
rename inflation to corn pop then maybe
biden will know how to handle it
no we just make another cereal out of it
it'll make him actually care about it
hope that corn pop i gotta stop that
thing
define logics and say forest it's your
favorite gun shop employee always loves
seeing you on tim's podcast oh thanks
man i'll see you later this week
problem right a bunch of people saying
we should have tom mcdonald on uh we'd
love to but he's a busy guy doing busy
stuff
andrew irvin says conservatism is a
naturally reactionary ideology it will
always be on defense and will never take
or re-take a ground and if you're not
willing to do it necessary to win then
you deserve to lose
fair dually no
i don't agree
we have one from an ian crossland he
says bash slash or pierce the like
button very violent yeah very violent
watch out he didn't include karate chop
or knife hand lots of no e and we peeing
ethereal project says have you guys seen
inside job on netflix it's all of the
shadow government conspiracies in one
animated show it's like an alex jones
wet dream yeah but it's it's like
interesting to watch to see what they do
but it's not funny
did you watch it luke no you didn't nope
really nope there was oh the cartoon
yeah okay yeah i watched some of it and
then it was like a psyop and then a
psyop of a psyop and and it got really
convoluted and in it and it and it was
more involved than pushing there is
certain points rather than actually
writing a good story there is one funny
joke in it where one of the characters
is a sentient psychic mushroom from
under like hollow earth and it it talks
about how joe keeps trying to hit him up
to do like do shrooms or something i
actually thought that was pretty funny
to do what to do to like to do to like
do psychedelics some some of the
characters are really interesting and
and the plot is is kind of different but
at the end of the day it's it's the same
kind of hollywood movie and series that
you see with the same underlining
messages that are just tiresome at this
point boring cairo says tim i truly hope
tensions in this country never break
into open conflict i've tried thinking
what we could expect based on history
and the events that stood out to me were
kansas 1855 russia 1917 and spain 1936.
i agree with those which one except for
wha what was what was kansas in 85. i
think it was called bleeding kansas
yeah i don't know 1855.
i do remember studying this in school
but i don't remember it yeah and if you
don't want violence i understand that
and i think that's a good nobody and you
know who also doesn't want violence all
the people who are good at it if you
want to ask yourself a good question why
is it that all the people who are
actually good at violence are not
participating in it they do not want it
yeah so 1855 was bleeding kansas and
this was john brown okay yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah was that when you
walked into the dude and
shot him in the face because because
kansas was looking at becoming a
southern state yeah slave state or
something like that yeah it was violent
guerrilla warfare between pro and
anti-slavery forces following the
creation of new territory of kansas but
think about this that's 18 that's what
six years before the civil war
so people don't understand this when i
talk about the tensions we're seeing in
this country and it's not just me like
we have we have a book over here
somewhere called the next civil war
where they like outline this there are
many people talking about it of course
they're all blaming
each other which is indicative of civil
war uh bring the war home by kathleen
bellow well you're already you're
already participating in it you started
your show saying like oh we're off the
silicon valley infrastructure that's a
form of secession in itself dennis
prager on the show said the other day
where you know people are pulling out of
public schools and doing homeschooling
we're in every mode of this until the
kinetic physical there have to be two
economies in order for a civil civil war
to begin because if one side controls
the flow of resources there's no war
they just cut off one side and then
you'll get insurgency or something but
if a parallel economy forms and it
already has
then you'll end up with something
different now maybe it's just always
going to be an information war
propaganda and you know we'll see let me
let me let me throw this in there if if
the libs hate oil so much why not just
like keep it away from them yeah there
you go they can give it to everyone else
right and then we'll see how they they
operate greta tunberg says shut down all
the oil now okay let's tell all the
cities how about we do that we shut it
all down from i'm cool with that let's
actually give them the world they want
yeah they have it yeah we'll keep the
oil yes
all right martin edgar says i'm
extremely disappointed with the nra the
left yells out the nra but my view of
them is they are willing to give
concessions to fight everything let's
see what they come out and say about
those people who caved you kidding the
nra always caves they're trash i hate
the nra oh no i think the nr is a great
institution it's fantastic and the
reason why it's so great is because it's
become the whipping boy of people who
don't know what they're talking about
that's a good point no i mean like
and our generation i'm 32 has every
reason to be extremely disappointed in
the nra because we've watched you
grandstand and make your your points
come from gun culture you know who the
nra just put back as their president
the same guy they fired for embezzlement
wayne lapierre
right so maybe maybe the stories that
were told about him weren't true if you
believe that find out for yourself but
no the nra is the nra if you if if you
are honest
if you are
on the left or you are a pro gun control
advocate and you are honest about the
conversation
stop talking about the nra because as
soon as you say that
we recognize you're not worth engaging
with they're great at fundraising
no they're fundraising their fundraising
platform is dying of old age you either
die a hero or live long enough to see
yourself become the villain what will
happen i mean you know right all right
selrin says nick ricketta talks about
the first scotus gun control case the
guy died before the hearing and his
lawyer didn't get paid so he didn't show
up the state argued against itself and
won the case
wow amazing nice wow
all right peter
provenzano says out of the people at the
table tonight how many have families you
are all in your 30s and don't even have
your first kid lead by example you can't
tell me what to do also i'm not in my
30s and not married sheamus is in his
40s
he's an old man
he's far in dust
i won't tell anything yeah yeah no i'm
not saying i also think that a lot of
people don't want to just blurt out
their private lives for security reasons
even if i was having a family i wouldn't
tell anybody i mean luke has three
why do you want the government
acknowledging your private relations i'm
with you on that thank you why do i want
the government you got me there yeah you
got me stop right there barbara stokes
says i am a boomer i am 65 you are wrong
about boomers but i forgive you i don't
remember what i said about boomers what
did i say about i think it might have
been something that you said i hate
boomers especially if they're 65 i
couldn't
there's criticism to be leveled at the
boomer generation 100 percent and and
millennials and soon can i add something
to that you know a lot of the money that
we spent
that's in the deficit was like spent to
like squeeze out like one percent of
life expectancy for like a bunch of
people mostly boomers yeah you know so
that's you know
you spent a lot on our heads mike take
the criticism no it's going to be really
weird so right now dis boomers hold a
disproportionate amount of wealth
relative to previous generations at this
time millennials i was looking at this
chart said historically millennials now
that they're in their 30s should hold a
quarter or a third of the wealth of the
nation but boomers still hold it
when boomers die
and that wealth either goes to the state
or to their kids it's going to be a it's
going to be like a tsunami hitting all
of a sudden millennials are going to
have the homes the resources and the
wealth that their parents were holding
on to for a long time which might which
might encourage people to be closer to
their families if they're twisted yeah
i'm reading a book by a boomer and the
boomer talked about how they will one
day be in charge of the economy and now
they are it was written in 1990 is
extremely condescending and my greatest
criticisms against the boomer generation
is you outright failed or refused to
pass your values or any values onto your
children because you said things like i
don't want to force timmy to believe
anything right good now timmy believes
nothing and how many how many of these
parents or anything i know i know a ton
of uh
you know people i grew up with whose
parents were like i got them the guitar
but i i didn't force them to play it i
got them the skateboard but i didn't
force them to use it and now i know a
bunch of people who suck at anything
don't know have worthless degrees and
there's a skateboarding guitar sitting
in the corner of the room they never
touched then i know some people who are
pro skateboarders and they were like my
my dad made me go to the skate park
because he was like if i buy you a
skateboard you're going to skate and
they're like okay then two weeks later
said i don't want to skate anymore too
bad we're going to the skatepark i
bought it for you you're going to do it
now they're pros
now they're rich successful and they
love sk they love it and they're like oh
it's the greatest thing that my parents
ever did for me well and there's an
irony here right millennials if they end
up having wealth a lot of it's going to
be inherited from their parents and this
is the generation that's pushing for
inheritance taxes because they've been
so thoroughly propagandized by the state
into believing that they exclusively
benefit the rich and that they have an
entitlement to other people's money and
that that will solve the issue of income
and equality it actually makes it worse
according to a number of analyses let's
read some more pablo gonzalez says i
hear you suggest kyle and crystal they
advocate protesting outside of judges
houses they go as far as saying the
right is trying to restrict speech over
this i'm not sure you watch their
content not can not i don't watch all
the stuff they do i see it periodically
my point about crystal and kyle is that
yeah i don't agree with their opinions
but i think they actually try to
approach arguments in good faith like
you can you can actually talk to them
kyle's not a mean guy either i've seen
him criticize me and it was like well
done but i disagree
that's fine i think they're wrong i just
think there's a lot of people that just
engage in sophistry i think kyle and
crystal actually try to give you real
arguments and they try to understand
their positions
i just don't agree with a lot of them
that's fair
we need more of that jimmy dore is great
too i certainly don't agree with jimmy
dore in a lot of things but i think
jimmy's fantastic he's he's a good dude
i like jimmy dore too yeah
it's it's like it's like my thing is you
know we disagree on so much you know
especially you know like ian's here and
luke or all of us we all have different
opinions sheamus and i disagree on
things but if we're coming at it from
like what are the facts and what what
are the arguments and why do we feel the
way we do then we're we're trying you
know
i actually agree with everyone here on
everything i've never disagreed with you
guys before even me especially you yeah
wow all right beastly devil says matt
walsh once critiqued vosh that reacted
to his johnny the walrus book he made
the argument that vosh is trying
and as we know already trying to meet
the minimum word count on an essay
project to make them sound smart this is
literally what the left does to try and
sound smart correct they think that if
they talk like this and use verbose
verbose lexicon in their explanations of
things it will make them sound much more
articulate and intelligent and their
argument will be more cogent and
acceptable instead of just being like i
think this because of this and also the
the the double edge to that is they say
that they say oh what you can't read my
explanation it's too many words for you
well you're uneducated yeah you're dumb
that's why you don't understand it you
don't want to understand why too many
words for you maggot you know well hey
look you know what they say wordiness is
the soul of what that's right
but that's that it's part of that it's
like wow you you don't understand this
giant treatise well obviously you're
uneducated nobody should listen to you
right they mistake education for
intelligence well also they mistake the
idea of they they mistake the purpose of
communicating with trying to make
themselves sound smart rather than
trying to get an actual idea across so
it doesn't matter if you're really
trying to communicate something then
what you should do is try to condense it
into something that's more consumable
that's part of why i've like dedicated
my life and my business towards making
short cartoons some things cannot be
reduced into a small format and that's
true that's true i agree with you
there's a reason for a dissertation
there's a reason for a long paper it
makes sense however
you have the same people who are trying
to present they are being intelligent
presenting while also simultaneously
that saying that intelligent presenting
is also racist because insert minority
here can't do it then why do you talk
that way this is all i will i will say i
agree with you that there are some
explanations that require a longer form
100
but it's also the case that if you can
communicate that same idea with less
words you are more intelligent they
never even consider that oh yeah let's
read some more we got fear me 16 it says
once heard and coulter say there are a
lot of bad republicans but there are no
good democrats
interesting
i mean what do you guys think of dennis
kucinich i know he's not like around in
politics anymore is he he's like he's an
old guy i think yeah yeah
because he had he tried to abolish the
federal reserve didn't he yeah he's a
democrat i think right right and i'm
kind of like oh i heard that and i was
like oh really that
yeah there's not i don't think there's
there's a lot less good democrats right
and that's another thing it's a totally
different generation the democrat then
the democrat now is just too
majorly different well the democrats
attacked him and kicked him out of
office
oh yeah
that was going up against the system
is this another
questions
bernie sanders just caved it was like
after my third house i was like okay
hillary whatever you say you know on the
bernie thing you know everyone points at
the houses right but have you guys
actually looked at like the political
infrastructure of bernie it's like his
wife runs the consultancy right and so
so basically think about that structure
right there he goes and asks for
donations gets the campaign gets
donations then he pays his wife to run
the run the campaign
baptism that's donation money finding
its way directly into the sanders
pockets right and it's blatant it's been
happening for years in vermont
and nobody says anything
i mean at least they're married it's not
like aoc you paid a non-boyfriend money
to do something was that was that her
nose
paid her and that their boyfriend and
girlfriend now yeah i mean i'm i'm from
minnesota i should have known those
ilhon but like okay at least bernie
sanders has it on the paperwork that
he's being dishonest well also
the administrative state approves of
your corruption yes i mean shout out to
the republicans that made a bunch of
money at the stock market too like yeah
i i don't know dan crenshaw
the reason i bring up and love
discussing bernie's houses is because so
much of his constituency thinks that
being a landlord makes you the scum of
the earth and i find something hilarious
about the idea that it's okay to own
three houses when you only need to live
in one and keep the other two vacant in
case you might like to go there but it's
horrible and evil to own three houses
live in one and allow other people to
live in the other two houses because no
communist thinks they're going to end up
a dirt farmer yeah oh you know because
you know what yes when you're a
communist you're when you're gonna be
the poet well yeah when you're it's the
same thing with um anarchist utopians no
one thinks that they're going to be the
one beaten to death with a cut i think
everybody's going to be running the
pilot bureau we got dan pitt he says
werewolf makes sense now that's right a
woman who transforms into a wolf monster
would be a whiff wolf if you are going
by actual like germanic language
a whiff wolf
a werewolf a wiffle bat
nitro cat official says matriarchy has
been tried before the episode of
survivor where it was the men versus
women the men had a shelter within the
day and the woman got caught in a storm
yo i i
some say
that all these videos are just
fabricated for ratings one of them i
watched it was like two islands the men
on one on the other the women got lost
and then
like they were like let's split up we'll
go look for water you stay here and the
women went to look for water walked
around in circles like five times
started crying and breaking down because
they didn't understand how they had gone
in circles because they were like
setting markers but they kept going in
circles and then they did this overview
of the map and they're like showing the
route they kept taking and they were
freaking out the men had a shelter they
had fire they had food
some say they they did that to make an
entertaining video that people would
share and talk about it was
intentionally like guys who had skills
and women who didn't
but nonetheless those those episodes of
they do exist well have you considered
that those women were raised in a
patriarchal society that didn't teach
them survival skills and that's why they
failed it's an indictment of sexism
because this is the patriarchy
they were taught they were taught how to
do it
the the instruction was simple go find a
man
go find you a man
the second protects the rest says the
fbi under trump is the exact same fbi
under biden yeah i want to write that
point yeah that is correct
trump's fbi i don't think it's trump
trump's fbi or biden's fbi i think it
it's the fbi and then they don't own
trump but they do own biden and so it's
the institutions are of themselves right
the fbi is the fbi it'll sit there and
it will be if the
administration the executive branch
that's supposed to run it tries to you
know come after them it's going to
resist if if you try to you know so the
the institution once it gets large
enough will just seek to preserve itself
right and that's why again it's all just
a shuffle in in some other universe
mueller would have been the
been trump's ag and bill barr would have
been doing the the special counsel i
think our competition i think our
commenter makes a good point is that you
can talk about the corruption in the
justice system all day long but you have
to protect you have to provide a
solution and alternative part of that
solution would be if you're the
department of justice seek justice i
think there's a part of it you have to
seek justice my solution is personnel is
policy get the person who believes what
you want what you need in there and they
will do the rest yeah let's read let's
read some more we got uh levati says
just blew my family's mind today with
the whole eight and nine month elective
abortions that are happening in some
states i have never seen a more
disgusted face god speed with what y'all
do and keep it up this is what happens
democrats tried to legalize
ayton abortion at any time for the
health of the mother
abortion is defined by the cdc as a
termination of a pregnancy that does not
result in a live birth that would mean
if a woman at eight and a half months
was at risk
they could kill the baby instead of just
delivering a viable baby because it says
a viable baby bowl all of it's laid out
my question is well why why not just say
if the baby cannot survive like all
attempts must be made to save the baby
and
the immediate response is it never
happens anyway why are you so obsessed
with this and i'm like i didn't say it
was happening i said why do you want to
legalize it mm-hmm yeah that's why
that's all i'm saying and this is we we
talked about this we've talked about uh
this on the show a number of times but
they'll say health of the mother and
then there are late term abortion
doctors who'll say yeah the most cited
reason is depression yeah so people
think like oh we have to deliver this
baby early or she's going to die it's
like no she's depressed no no no no
they're saying some instances
in this instance they're literally
saying if if a woman's health isn't
impacted for any reason they can be like
guess we got to kill the baby but it's
like what if we delivered it instead
nope nope it has to die do you guys know
the statistics on on the abortions and
stuff it's not great it's uh i think
over 90 of abortions are like just
it's like it's over 90. and so that
means rape incest and medical go in like
what 10 percent 10 percent
less than that
yeah although
and that is the disingenuous nature of
the conversation right because you say
we want to we have
we have the issue of abortion and they
say well what about rape
really really like say yes okay no no no
i mean so you want to ban the other 93
and they'll go no no no then don't lie
about it just stop lying i just i say
this to people when they're like well
what about rape and instance i'm like oh
we'll make sure there's exceptions for
that and they're like okay and i'm like
so would you ban the other 93 then and
they go no then why did you bring an
album right why did you ask me that
correct it's it's dishonest stop being
dishonest or just just
sure but i wouldn't say that i'd just be
like oh okay why'd you ask
why did you ask oh because you're
dishonest i got you yeah but if you
wanna actually like
i don't think the word is dishonest i
think it's subversive
yeah but i think a lot of people are
just repeating talking points so you
just approach it like oh okay yeah
you're right we should definitely allow
that then so what about the elective
birth control abortion should we get rid
of that no okay then why'd you bring up
rape at all
like when we had when we had that dude
matt on he said something like this
never happens tim light term abortions
don't happen and then i was and then i
said do you think a woman should be
allowed to have an elective abortion at
nine months and he goes it's her choice
and i'm like okay you see there's the
issue you're saying it never happens it
never happens legalize it and i think it
i think it should be allowed i'm like
okay that's my issue you want it to
happen
whatever man you would let it happen
right because that's that's really what
it is they want it to happen they think
it should happen
so there you go and if you don't affirm
that they should happen then we're going
to burn down your pregnancy resource
centers all right your wait it's awesome
is it really yours is it really yours
this is what they say because it
represents something that isn't mine so
i'll burn it down yeah exactly well this
is what they say if you know pro-lifers
don't care about these women they don't
care after about children after they're
born and then when pro-lifers literally
have charities and organizations set up
to provide these women with resources
when they're brave enough to bring life
into the world pro-choicers torch them
that's what they're doing imagine let's
read some more here we got dark
derivative says tim gaslighting and
lying is what got us here it will not
get us out you won't read this well oh
the last part of that sentence is wrong
i guess the rest of it must be wrong too
right
you cannot defeat gasoline you're good
at the super chat stuff man oh yeah
all right we'll just grab uh let's just
grab a couple more here
a couple more super jets
raymond g stanley jr says tim did you
write will of the people i did i wrote
it i sang it i wrote the guitar for it
not the music version not the muse
version no that one's not that good i
don't like it i'm a big fan of you
though but i just didn't like that um
also i feel like they kind of ripped off
a lot of my my art and style and you
know whatever but uh yes i have a song
it's called will of the people and you
can search for it listen to it i sang it
i wrote the guitar for it lead guitar
was a studio musician
and uh nishra allman produced the song
and arranged it and worked with some
outside uh talent to to put it all
together i wrote the story i wrote the
concept for the video and all of that
from creation inception was mine except
for all the nitty-gritty pieces that
were putting everything together so yeah
i'm very excited for that we also have a
bunch of music coming out maybe by
august i think we have a full album we
have 10 songs demo tracked already one
is complete we have a couple that are
near completion we're working with uh
pete parata formerly of the offspring on
drums so i'm super excited for that and
we have a big plan for a big release
with big marketing it should be like a
very traditional album release so anyway
thanks for hanging out guys if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
head over to timcast.com and become a
member if you want to help support all
of the work we do it's basically how we
make the operation run we do a show on
podcast and then tell everybody support
us
ads aren't really the heavy lifting for
the most part
it's membership so if you really do want
to help us get more journalists expand
the operation launch more shows that's
how you do it don't forget to follow us
on instagram at tim cast irl where we
post clips every day you can follow me
at timcast and smash that like button
vish you want to shout anything out
shout out to the new york young
republican club follow us
nyyyrc.com and uh yeah pay attention to
uh the good things coming up man we have
a hot midterm and uh yeah i'm gonna be
in there from new york 23 trying to win
back the house for republicans and um
you know just pay attention
cool yeah my name is forrest cooper i am
the philosopher on violence if you want
to follow me on instagram my personal
page is f-o-x-r-o-e underscore official
for foxra official the business page for
redacted is at redacted llc and then my
personal instagram instagram twitter
page which i occasionally use is um at
foxrow and that's where you can find me
right now first of all uh shouts out to
uh lydia's better half andy he uh he
builds a lot of the cool stuff uh out
here today is his birthday he's a really
cool awesome human being so shouts out
today happy birthday and he's pretty
incredible and i'm leaving um
it wasn't because of video games uh i
just got my own thing to do and i'm
gonna be doing a lot of different stuff
projects shenanigans you could keep up
with me on lukeuncensored.com
um and if you guys will have me back
i'll come back after i'm done doing my
my radowski stuff and uh
he's doing some weird hippie acupuncture
retreat or something of course
they're gonna like rub crystals on his
head whatever he's doing on my buttocks
this is a family-friendly show timothy
paul
whatever he's doing it's not important
but the important thing is he won't be
here oh my god everybody how charitable
sheamus off to the potato
luke i will miss you believe it or not
better i will look i mean there's got to
be someone to take the heat on this show
but i'm seamus coughlin i make cartoons
we released a cartoon yesterday about uh
the attempted
assassination of kavanaugh and how the
left and responding to that and inciting
that so you guys might want to check
that out also i have a website now
because we're trying to get independent
from big tech so go to freedomtunes.com
you can become a member for just five
bucks a month you'll be supporting the
content that we're making you will also
get an extra cartoon each week as well
as behind the scenes content so we've
already got like i think seven cartoons
up there now and then uh a bunch of
behind the scenes stuff did you do the
voices on all the freedom tunes most of
them tim uh plays fauci and then there's
a female voice actress who does most of
the female voices but i do most of them
i also did that
and the one antifa guy that's right i
think a cop once as well yes yes can i
say freedom tunes radicalized to me
see the good work we're doing go to
freedomtunes.com and become a member to
help support us yes wonderful thank you
guys for tuning in on this most
wonderful of national holidays that is
my husband's birthday he's 27 again and
just as youthful as he actually was when
he was 27. you guys may follow him at
andyleiderman on twitter and instagram
and you can follow me at sarahpathlets
on twitterminds.com as well as lids dot
me we will see all of you over at well
actually no it's friday night it's
friday we will see all of you over at
cast castle go to youtube.comcastcastle
in the the last three videos we think we
did maybe it's three uh jamie kilstein
the community has been on the show
several times he's coming on to help us
produce the uh the comedy portions of
the cass castle vlog when we first
launched it the idea was to do a vlog
and then mix in you know comedic bits
and and funny things we we had one in
the beginning where like luke blew up
the castle on his way i was very simple
and then since then we've been trying to
get into the habit of making it kind of
like a semi-fictionalized version of of
the work we do here to make it funny
jamie has absolutely done that we have a
whole bunch of plans all these crazy
jokes written out it's gonna be a whole
lot of fun so check out
youtube.comcastcastle
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you